Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 43, Debugging. Take it away, Patrick. I want to start off with a rant. I very ranty person so this is easy for me this one is every time are you a ranty person yes that's true i rant a lot i need to see these
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 43 期，调试。开始吧，Patrick。我想先发发牢骚。我是一个很爱发牢骚的人，所以这对我来说很容易，每次都是这样。你是一个爱发牢骚的人吗？是的，没错，我经常发牢骚。我需要看看这些
long emails that you send your co-workers no i don't i do it verbally because emails can be reproduced and like held against you versus like someone just recollecting what you said. And then you go, I didn't say that. I didn't say that. The worst is don't put an email. I don't want to talk about this in email. Sounds like proof you were doing something bad. Yeah.
你发给同事的长邮件。不，我不会。我都是口头说的，因为邮件是可以被留存的，可能会被用来对付你，而口头交流别人只能凭记忆复述。然后你可以说：“我没说过那样的话。”最糟糕的就是不要发邮件。我不想在邮件里谈论这个。这听起来就像是你做了什么坏事的证据。是的。
Don't ever write an email saying like the lawyers will have a field day with this. Like, don't do that, please. Yeah. saying like the lawyers will have a field day with this like don't do that please um yeah so my thing is every time someone at work or on the internet whatever says i have a really easy programming problem that i think every programmer should be able to solve um and my rant is that uh so i work at a company that does technical interviews so if you do an interview for my company, then you have to actually like program as part of the interview. And I try to be very sensitive to the fact that programming during an interview is a very, very tough thing to do. And not everyone does. But I try to be very sensitive that fact, because a lot of times when other people who do interviews tell me their
千万不要写那种说“律师会因为这个大做文章”之类的邮件。拜托，千万别那样做。是的，所以我的观点是，每当工作或互联网上有人说“我有一个非常简单的编程问题，我认为每个程序员都应该能解决”时，我的牢骚就来了。我工作的公司负责技术面试，所以如果你参加我们公司的面试，你必须在面试中实际编写程序。我尽量考虑到在面试中编程是一件非常、非常困难的事情。并不是每个人都能做到。但我尽量体谅这一点，因为很多时候，当其他人告诉我他们的
interview problems, I think, well, I don't know how to solve that um and the truth is if i sat in the room and like tried like had to do it i probably could work through it um but i think my problem and i think a lot of other people have this problem is that there can be edge cases which even the person asking the problem either is being nefarious in having there or hasn't even thought of themselves yeah i had this situation where someone asked me to solve some interview question and then at some point during the interview they realized that they had just created a very bad question and didn't know it and it's it's not hard to do it's super easy to to make this mistake because like it's like anything right you don't
面试题时，我想，嗯，我不知道该怎么解决。事实是，如果我坐在房间里尝试去做，我可能能解决它。但我认为我的问题，以及我认为很多人都有这个问题，那就是可能存在一些边缘情况，即使是出题的人，要么是故意设下的陷阱，要么是他们自己都没考虑到。是的，我遇到过这种情况，有人让我解决某个面试题，然后在面试过程中的某个时刻，他们意识到自己出了一个非常糟糕的题目，却浑然不知。这并不难，犯这种错误太容易了，因为就像任何事情一样，你不会
see like all the possible nuances that could happen so the classic one i remember is that i was in association for computing machinery programming competition in college and we went to one of the competitions with other schools and there was a question about they gave you a layout of supposedly an unfolded cube. So if you took a cube and you kind of like if it was made of paper and you unfolded it at the various faces laying on the table and it forms a pattern. Right. And there's various different patterns that form cubes. The easiest one being four squares in a row and then two wings kind of on opposite sides of the line. So if you have four squares in a row, one over, one under. But there are actually other valid patterns which form squares. And so when we looked at this problem,
看到所有可能发生的细微差别。我记得最经典的一个例子是，我在大学参加计算机协会编程竞赛时，我们和其他学校一起参加比赛，其中有一个问题是给你一个所谓的展开立方体的布局。如果你拿一个立方体，假设它是纸做的，你把它展开，让各个面平铺在桌子上，它会形成一种图案。没错。有各种不同的图案可以组成立方体。最简单的是一行四个正方形，然后在直线的两侧各有两个“翅膀”。所以如果你有一行四个正方形，上面一个，下面一个。但实际上还有其他有效的图案可以组成正方形。所以当我们看这个问题时，
they give you a pattern and you had to say whether or not it formed a complete cube. I actually remember solving exactly that problem. It was like the Southeast Regional Qualifier, right? It might have been. We may have. You and I didn't know each other then, but we may have both been there at this time. Oh, interesting. So this was a problem presented.
他们给你一个图案，你必须判断它是否能组成一个完整的立方体。我确实记得解决过那个问题。那好像是东南赛区的预选赛，对吧？可能是吧。我们可能……那时我们还不认识，但我们可能都在场。哦，有意思。所以这就是当时提出的一个问题。
And one of the teams from our school afterwards talked about, oh, yeah, we saw this is really easy. You just look for four in a row horizontally or four vertically and then the two wings. And then you'll know, is it Cuban? If it's not, it's not. And they actually got it right submitting that solution. And then we pointed out, yeah, but there's edge cases where it's much more difficult to solve. You actually have to think about it in a more nuanced manner so our team didn't even end up attempting it uh to solve the problem because you know we thought like oh it'd be take a long time to figure out how to actually do all these edge cases um and it was probably solvable but it
我们学校的一支队伍事后说：“哦，是的，我们看到了，这很简单。你只要找水平一行四个或垂直一行四个，然后加上两个翅膀。然后你就知道它是不是立方体了。如果不是，那就不是。”他们提交了这个方案，竟然还做对了。然后我们指出：“是的，但有些边缘情况解决起来要困难得多。你实际上必须以更细致的方式思考。”所以我们的团队甚至没有尝试去解决这个问题，因为你知道，我们想：“哦，弄清楚如何处理所有这些边缘情况会花很长时间。”它可能是有解的，但它
turned out you didn't need to because the uh set the test set they used only had the most easy case in it this you know four in a row in two weeks it was super i happen to remember i mean not to go on like a rant on a rant but but that specific year that year i did particularly bad in the competition like our team did particularly bad and uh i remember a lot of the problems like i remember there being problems with the competition like that was one of them like that one i think we solved but it took a long time and other people solved it immediately and we couldn't figure out why yeah this is why yeah there was some other one where um just there was some there was an error in the test set and and no team got it right but it was kind of bs like oh man yeah i hated that year yeah i did yeah i did bad that year um but
结果证明你不需要这样做，因为他们使用的测试集只包含了最简单的情况，也就是“一行四个加两个翅膀”。这太……我碰巧记得，不是要没完没了地发牢骚，但那一年我在比赛中表现特别差，我们的团队表现特别差。我记得很多问题，比如其中一个，我想我们解决了，但花了很多时间，而其他人立刻就解决了，我们搞不懂为什么。是的，这就是原因。还有另一个问题，测试集里有一个错误，没有队伍做对，但这有点扯淡。天哪，是的，我讨厌那一年。是的，我那一年表现很差，但是
okay so the reason that this rant is spawned is because i was reading i don't remember hacker news or reddit and um this this thing came across a website we'll have it linked in the show notes um the oh this is a weird name the blog is svpino.com yeah i think it's his name okay i don't know how to say that and i don't know what the blog i never read any other articles el valderrama okay so i can't recommend if anything else on the website it's good but this particular post that he got that you know became pretty popular was five programming problems every software engineer should be able to solve in less than an hour uh so i'm not sure if he means hour total or hour each um but he basically talks about you know people this is the if you ever hear the fizz buzz, oh, every programmer should be able to solve this fizz buzz problem.
好吧，之所以会发这个牢骚，是因为我在读 Hacker News 或 Reddit，然后看到了这个东西，一个网站，我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。哦，这是一个奇怪的名字，博客是 svpino.com。是的，我想那是他的名字。好吧，我不知道怎么读，也不知道这个博客，我从来没读过其他文章。El Valderrama，好吧，所以我不能推荐网站上的其他内容，但这篇文章确实变得很受欢迎，题目是“每个软件工程师都应该在一小时内解决的五个编程问题”。我不确定他指的是总共一小时还是每个问题一小时。但他基本上谈到了人们……这就是如果你听说过 Fizz Buzz，哦，每个程序员都应该能解决这个 Fizz Buzz 问题。
You can look it up. Anyways, that, you know, people apply for programming jobs and they can't actually write just a for loop. You know, I want a for loop. This is like, this is actually a real problem. You think about it, like you can get somebody who no matter what they have on paper, like it's always possible. And it's even sometimes like probable that you will get someone who applies, who like literally does not know how to program. I mean, you can go through an entire computer science degree.
你可以查一下。总之，人们申请编程工作，却连一个 for 循环都写不出来。你知道，我想要一个 for 循环。这实际上是一个真正的问题。你想想，无论简历上写着什么，你总是有可能，甚至有时很可能会遇到一个申请人，他真的不知道怎么编程。我的意思是，你可以读完整个计算机科学学位。
Like it's actually harder in the U S but especially more in like Europe and Asia, you can get like a PhD in computer science and never have written a single program it's entirely possible it is true i do give likely interview questions sometimes and the way to start off is you know kind of starts with like essentially write a for loop that goes through an array and looks for a specific number right no tricks no anything and yeah a lot of people can't get who have computer science degrees can't get that question and again i'm sensitive to the fact that in interviews it's very hard but okay so he gives a couple uh you know he gives up five
在美国这其实更难，但在欧洲和亚洲尤其如此，你可以获得计算机科学博士学位，却从未写过一个程序，这完全有可能。这是真的，我有时确实会出一些面试题，开始的方式通常是，你知道，基本上就是写一个遍历数组并查找特定数字的 for 循环，对吧？没有技巧，什么都没有。是的，很多拥有计算机科学学位的人都做不到这个问题。再说一次，我体谅在面试中这非常困难，但好吧，他给出了几个……他给出了五个
problems and the first uh two are really straightforward the third one uh is pretty easy calculate fibonacci numbers okay that that's actually i mean you can't use the brute force recursion way for only the first hundred so you actually can um uh yeah two to the hundredth that's like pretty huge still right no no but on a modern computer i think i think you're fine for the first hundred fair enough um also i think you he wants you to do it it looks like he's trying to say iteratively so you actually can just go through the whole list so you can just wait two to the hundredth no two still pretty, it's not 2 to the 100. No, that's the complexity.
问题，前两个非常简单，第三个相当容易，计算斐波那契数。好吧，那实际上……我的意思是，你不能对前一百个数使用暴力递归法。所以你实际上可以……嗯，2 的 100 次方，那还是相当大的，对吧？不，不，但在现代计算机上，我想你应该没问题，对于前一百个数。好吧，有道理。另外，我想他希望你用迭代法来做，所以你实际上可以遍历整个列表，所以你可以直接等 2 的 100 次方……不，不，那还是相当……不是 2 的 100 次方。不，那是复杂度。
Yeah, if you want the first 100 Fibonacci numbers, then like each, it's a split, right? Well, yes, if you calculate the 100th number recursively, naively. Yeah, right. That's true. But if you're doing it iteratively, you just have to keep an array and add the previous two numbers. No, no, I get that.
是的，如果你想要前 100 个斐波那契数，那么就像，这是一个拆分，对吧？嗯，是的，如果你天真地递归计算第 100 个数。是的，没错。那是真的。但如果你用迭代法，你只需要保留一个数组并加上前两个数。不，不，我明白。
But I'm saying like, yeah, yeah, yeah. But what i'm saying is he's not asking for the nth number he's actually saying print the first 100 in a row oh which leads you to like doing it iteratively okay fair enough fair so i don't actually know to 100 may or may not i don't know okay but but okay that's why i'm saying that one maybe maybe not not. Okay. Right. Then the problem four, which I won't describe, you can go read. But basically, he gives you an array of numbers, 52, 1, 9, different numbers. And he's saying arrange them in any way possible to form the largest number if you kind of concatenate the digits together. Oh, okay. And he's saying this is like, oh, this is really easy. He presents, you know, he at some point presented a solution
但我说的是，是的，是的，是的。但我说的是他不是在问第 n 个数，他实际上是在说按顺序打印前 100 个。哦，这引导你用迭代法去做。好吧，有道理。所以我实际上不知道 100 个可能或可能不……我不知道。好吧，但好吧，这就是为什么我说那个可能……可能不是。好吧。然后是第四个问题，我就不描述了，你可以去读。但基本上，他给你一个数字数组，52, 1, 9，不同的数字。他说把它们以任何可能的方式排列，如果你把数字连接在一起，形成最大的数字。哦，好吧。他说这就像，哦，这真的很容易。他展示了，你知道，他在某个时候提出了一个解决方案
that turned out not to even be correct. Yeah, this seems like extremely freaking hard. That's what I thought too. And I was like, oh, I feel really bad because random person on the internet says this is an easy question and I don't know that I could get it. I think this is, yeah, I mean, obviously like the numbers won't have that many digits, but I'm pretty sure this is uh yeah i mean i mean obviously like the numbers won't have that many
结果证明甚至是不正确的。是的，这看起来极其困难。我也是这么想的。我当时想，哦，我感觉很糟糕，因为互联网上的一个随机的人说这是一个简单的问题，而我不知道我能不能做出来。我认为这是……是的，我的意思是，显然数字不会有那么多位数，但我很确定这是……是的，我的意思是，显然数字不会有那么多
digits but i'm pretty sure this is like np complete where n is like the number of digits so like this could get hard right yes and depends like he doesn't give a bound here that like could the numbers each be are the numbers in the array there'd be a hundred numbers in the array like yeah right uh i don't know uh and then the last one is he gives you a list of numbers and you're supposed to uh put pluses or minus between them arbitrarily so that their sum is 100 again this is not straight like to me that's an incomplete problem this is not easy actually you might be able to use dynamic programming but yeah you're right like there's no they're not but these are not nobody i know can do all of these in an hour first time get it people won't be able to do
位数，但我很确定这就像是 NP 完全问题，其中 n 是数字的数量，所以这可能会变得很难，对吧？是的，取决于……他在这里没有给出界限，比如数组里的数字每个可能是……数组里可能有 100 个数字，对吧？我不知道。然后最后一个是，他给你一个数字列表，你应该在它们之间随意放置加号或减号，使它们的和为 100。同样，这并不直接……对我来说，这是一个不完整的问题，这实际上并不容易。你也许可以使用动态规划，但你是对的，没有……他们不是……但我认识的人没有谁能在一小时内完成所有这些。第一次做，人们将无法在
number five in an hour yes so my rant is simply that a lot of people say oh you know you should be able to do this in an hour this is easy for interviewing just be careful and don't like feel bad about yourself because like some random guy on the internet says you should be able to like oh this is easy and it turns out he may not even be right. And like Jason was pointing out, I also have seen people who said, this is an easy problem, told me what their interview problem was, told me what they think the solution is. And then I point out ways their solution is broken. And then like, oh, I forgot about those ways, you know, or something. So people sometimes like to say things are easy when they're really not.
一小时内完成第五个问题。是的，所以我的牢骚很简单，很多人说“哦，你应该能在一小时内完成这个，这对面试来说很简单”。要小心，不要因为互联网上某个随机的人说“你应该能做到，哦，这很简单”而感到难过，结果证明他甚至可能是错的。就像 Jason 指出的那样，我也见过有人说“这是一个简单的问题”，告诉我他们的面试题是什么，告诉我他们认为的解决方案是什么。然后我指出了他们解决方案中被破坏的地方。然后他们就说“哦，我忘了那些情况了”，或者类似的话。所以人们有时喜欢说事情很简单，而实际上并非如此。
Yeah, yeah, definitely. That's actually a good point. It's very hard in general, to figure out how difficult something is. And I mean, which true for interview coming up with interview questions, but also kind of as a metaphor for just being an engineer, especially, you know, when you have kind of time time constraints or when you have to impose define time constraints like someone tells you like how long is this going to take that that's a super hard question to answer and the good news is like in real life a lot of these problems i would solve by like we're saying you know how big can the array be um before you know it kind of takes too long it's like the way i would code it in real life which you can't do in an interview would be oh well i'll code it the naive way and then i'll put you know the you
是的，是的，绝对。这确实是一个很好的观点。总的来说，弄清楚某件事有多难是非常困难的。我的意思是，这对于面试出题来说是真的，但也作为一种隐喻，对于作为一名工程师来说也是如此，特别是当你有时限，或者当你必须强加定义时限时，比如有人问你“这需要多长时间”，这是一个非常难回答的问题。好消息是，在现实生活中，很多这样的问题我会通过像我们说的那样解决，比如“数组能有多大”，在它变得太慢之前。就像我在现实生活中编写代码的方式，你在面试中做不到，我会想：“哦，好吧，我会用天真的方式编写它，然后我会加上检查，确保我输入的数量少于我知道在合理时间内运行的数量。”然后基本上我们会尝试捕捉当它变成更多的情况。所以最初，哦，系统里只有五样东西，但有一天可能会有一百个。好吧，算法只在有 10 个时有效。好吧，我不会一开始就写出对一百个有效的算法。我会写出对 10 个有效的算法。然后我会确保代码有自我文档，并检查它是否小于 10。当它大于 10 时，我们基本上必须去重写它。嗯，也许我因为这样做是个糟糕的人，但我不想陷入分析瘫痪，而且人们太经常花时间为一百万的规模编写最优解，而它
know checks to make sure that the input amount i'll have is less than what i know runs in a reasonable time and then basically we'll try to catch when it goes to something more so initially like oh there's only five things in the system, but one day there may be a hundred. Well, the algorithm only works when there's 10. Well, I'm not going to write the algorithm that works for a hundred off the bat. I'll write the one that works for like 10. And then I'll just make sure the code self documents and checks that it's less than 10. And when it's greater than 10, we basically have to go rewrite it. Um, and maybe I'm a terrible person for doing that, but I don't want to get analysis paralysis uh and too often people spend the time writing the optimal for size million and they
最终从来没有超过五个或什么的。对吧，所以……所以那个人最终在他的博客里写了动态规划的解决方案，但这正是我们观点的完美例子，对吧？是的，Patrick 提出的观点是他使用动态规划解决了这个问题，他可能觉得非常聪明，但他把函数命名为 f，现在没人能理解他的代码是什么意思，而且没有文档，对吧？是的，好吧，重点是他开始的背景是“那些只知道如何编写 CSS 和 HTML 的人，不应该被称为程序员”。除非你能解决这个问题，否则你不应该称自己为程序员。这比我给“程序员”这个称呼设定的门槛要高得多。现在，可能你的公司不想雇佣一个不会动态规划的人，
never ends up being past size five or whatever right so so so the guy ends up writing the dynamic programming solution in his blog but i this is a perfect example of of like you know our point right yeah the point patrick's making is he solves the problem using dynamic programming and he probably feels really clever and everything but he calls his function f it's like now nobody can understand like you know what his code is but there's no documentation right yeah well and the point like he starts off with the context for it is like people who only know how to write you know css and html shouldn't be called a programmer you shouldn't be able to call yourself a programmer unless you can solve this problem and that's just really that's a bar far higher than i would put for calling yourself a programmer um now it may be that your company doesn't want to hire someone who can't do dynamic
当然，随便吧，这有待商榷。但这并不意味着他们不是程序员，或者不是一个好程序员，因为他们想不出动态规划的解决方案，对吧？我的意思是，归根结底，计算机很便宜，而且你编写易于阅读的代码，并确保如果你辞职，接替你的人能胜任，这比编写最好的动态规划解决方案重要得多，对吧？是的，我可以用一只手，也许两只手，数出我整个职业生涯中真正需要使用我所选择的算法并产生重大影响的次数。是的。大多数时候这并不重要。架构有时很重要，但像真正的教科书算法……
programming sure fine whatever that's up for debate but that doesn't mean they're not a programmer or a good programmer because they can't come up with dynamic programming solutions right i mean at the end of the day computers are cheap and uh you, making something that's easy to read and making it so that if you quit, the person behind you can take your place is way more important than writing the best dynamic programming solution, right? Yeah, I can count on one, maybe two hands, the number of times in my entire career where I've needed to use, like, the algorithm I chose actually made an impactful difference. Yeah. Most of the times it doesn't matter. Architecture can matter sometimes, but like, you know, true textbook algorithms.
总之，这是我的反牢骚。如果你真的想通过数据集来练习编程问题，我们有一些资源。一个是 Topcoder，即使你不参加 TopCoder 举办的比赛，他们也有过去的题库
Anyways, so my anti-rant, if you really want to go through programming problems with data sets and that like other people have done, we have some resources. One is Topcoder, which is, even if you don't do the competitions offered by TopCoder, they have past problem sets
以及示例输入和输出。所以你可以实际提交你的代码，看看它是否有效。他们给出的评价，我发现相当准确，尽管仍然相当困难。但他们说是简单的问题通常确实很简单。
and the example inputs and outputs. So you can actually submit your code and see if it works or not. And they give a pretty, what I find to be pretty accurate, although it's still pretty difficult. But the ones they say are easy are typically pretty easy.
现在，难题可能真的非常非常难，但简单的问题……好吧，关于 Topcoder 的一件事是，他们有社论。所以出题的人也会采用最好的解决方案。他们不仅采用自己的解决方案，这一点很好。实际上，在比赛结束后，他们会查看所有的解决方案，找到最有趣的一个，并记录下来，写下真正的社论，就像你一样，带有指向维基百科和 Math Stack Exchange 的链接等等。所以你可以参加 Topcoder 比赛，然后回去看社论，学习你不知道的东西。
Now, hard ones could be really, really hard, but the easy ones... Well, one thing about top coders, they have the editorials. So the people who write the problems also take the best solution. And they're good about not just taking their own solution. Like, actually, at the end of the contest, they look at all the solutions and they find the most interesting one and they document it and write literally write an editorial like you with links to wikipedia and like math dot stack exchange and everything so like you could do a top coder contest and then go back and look at the editorial and and learn what you didn't know
这非常棒。其他的也很好。我们会链接所有这三个。但 Topcoder 绝对是最好的，原因就在这里。哦，天哪，我的新闻文章先上，现在是新闻时间。我有的第一个链接，其实不算新闻，是 NAND to Tetris。所以 NAND 是一种逻辑门，与非门。所以它是一个与门加一个非门，它是
it's very awesome the other ones are good. We'll link all three of them. But Topcoder by far is the best for this reason. Oh man, my news article's up first and it's time for the news. The first link I have, which is not really news, is NAND to Tetris. So NAND is a type of logic gate, a not and. So it's an and with a not and it is one of
门之一，嗯，我想或非门是另一个，你可以用与非门构建所有其他逻辑门。所以非门、或门和异或门都可以完全由与非门构建。所以一旦你理解了与非门是如何工作的，你就可以把它们组合起来形成所有其他逻辑位，一旦你理解了逻辑位是如何工作的，你就可以构建电路，然后是计算机。所以这带你进入这个大规模在线课程 MOOC，M-O-O-C，是的，大规模在线什么课程……由……我不知道，实际上我会查一下……在 Coursera 上。所以我没上过这个，但我浏览了配套的教科书，我听说过关于这个的一些好东西。大规模开放在线课程。
the gates uh nor being the other one i think where you can build every other logic gate out of nan so knots ores and exclusive ores can be built entirely from nand gates so once you understand how a nand gate works you can combine them to form all other bits of logic and once you understand how the bits of logic work you can build circuits and then computers um and so this takes you this massively online course mooc m-o-o-c yeah massive online something course uh offered i don't know actually i'll look it up uh on coursera so i haven't taken this one but i skimmed through the accompanying textbook, and I heard some good stuff about this. Massive open online courses.
开放，开放，好吧。所以这是免费的吗？我不知道它出来多久了，我不能推荐我们将要链接的课程中的实际视频是否好，但他们有书。它带你从与非逻辑一直到构建微处理器，为该微处理器编写汇编语言。这是我的理解，通过
Open, open, okay. So is this free? I don't know how long it's been out, and I can't recommend whether or not the actual videos in the course that we'll link is good, but they have books. And it takes you all the way from NAND logic through building a microprocessor, writing assembly for that microprocessor. And this is my understanding through,
主要是通过模拟器而不是实际的芯片。但关于系统、微控制器架构、汇编的想法仍然存在。我想大概最后，你实际上在你用与非门构建的处理器上制作了一个俄罗斯方块游戏。我想我做过类似的事情，只是名字没那么酷，或者我们最后没有做俄罗斯方块，但我做过类似的事情。你
mostly through simulators versus actual chips. But the idea is still there about system, microcontroller architecture, assembly. And I guess supposedly at the end, you actually make a Tetris game on your processor that you've built from nand gates and i think this is something i did something of course pretty similar to this only it wasn't so awesomely named or uh we didn't make tetris at the end um but i did something similar you
从逻辑门一直到微处理器，你知道，你是从零开始的，这对于了解处理器是如何工作的，以及处理器设计中做出的权衡和决策非常有启发。酷。所以如果你是一个底层人员，或者你想了解更多，我推荐它。如果你是一个高层人员，我不知道，也许吧。我们有没有……我不认为我们解释过，如果我们解释过，那肯定也是几年前的事了。
go from all the way logic gates up to a microprocessor um you know you're on your own from scratch and that was really insightful into learning about how processors work and trade-offs and decisions that are made in processor design. Cool. So if you're a low level person or you want to learn more about it, I recommend it. If you're a high level person, I don't know, maybe. Do we ever, I don't think we ever explained if we haven't, if we've ever explained it, it's definitely been years ago.
所以底层，那并不意味着在等级制度中处于底层或类似的意思。底层意味着你工作得更接近硬件。不，我们谈过这个，对吧？那些正在致富的 CUDA 开发人员。哦，好吧。这意味着更低，意味着更接近硬件，这是一个隐喻，或者无论你怎么称呼它，一个隐喻，指编写汇编代码、C 代码，这些东西
So low level, that doesn't mean low on the totem pole or anything like that. Low level means that you're working closer to the metal. No, we talked about this, right? The guys doing CUDA who are getting rich. Oh, okay. It means lower, it means closer to the metal which which is a which is a metaphor uh your paraphrase or whatever you call it a metaphor for uh you know writing you know like assembly code c code things which are um things which
代码看起来非常类似于机器码，而不是像 Prolog 之类非常高级的东西。是的。对我来说，它还有更多的含义，比如你可以编写 C Linux 应用程序，我不会真的称之为底层，但如果你在编写 Linux，或者你在编写 Linux 驱动程序，或者你在
where the code looks very which looks more similar to machine code than, than something that's very high level, like like prologue or something. Yeah. It's also something more too, to me, like you could write C Linux applications and I wouldn't really call that low level per se, but like if you're writing Linux or you're writing Linux drivers or you're
编写在没有操作系统的情况下运行或控制硬件的东西，你知道，与 PCI 总线之类的东西对话，对吧？像这些涉及硬件的东西。你需要，例如，阅读供应商提供的硬件组件数据表，或者担心这些东西占用的时钟周期。你知道，像那种东西就变成了底层，是的。是的，这说得通。
writing stuff that runs without an operating system or controls hardware, you know, talks out to PCI bus stuff or, right? Like these kinds of things that involve hardware. And you need to, for instance, read vendor-supplied data sheets for hardware components or worry about clock cycles that stuff takes. You know, like that kind of stuff becomes low-level, yeah. Yeah, that makes sense.
所以我的链接是“为工程师创作艺术”，所以……等等，等等，艺术是给工程师欣赏的吗？不，这有点像……为工程师准备的，就像有一本“傻瓜书”一样。哦，好吧，所以这就像是……为艺术傻瓜创作艺术，以及教工程师如何创作艺术。完全正确，是的。所以我读了这篇文章，我还没有非常详细地阅读，但我确实认为它很酷。它以一种非常……嗯……它采取了一种肯定式，那是叫这个吗？还是祈使式？它采取了一种祈使立场，或者它有点……它全是用第二人称写的，比如“做这个，不要做那个，别忘了做那个”，这很酷。而且……是的，我觉得这是一篇很酷的文章。
So mine is creating art for engineers and so uh wait wait art to be enjoyed by engineers no this is sort of like uh uh four engineers in the sense of like like there'd be a book for dummies oh okay so this is like yeah creating art for art dummies so how and teaching engineers how to create art exactly yeah that's right and so uh i read through this i haven't gone through in great detail yet but i do think it's pretty cool it's written in a very sort of um uh it takes sort of the affirmative is that what that's called or the imperative it takes over an imperative stance or it's like kind of it's it's all written in the second person like do this don't do that don't don't forget to do that it's kind of cool um and uh yeah i thought it was pretty cool article
嗯，正如我在上一期节目中所说，开始画画作为一种爱好之类的东西，所以这对我来说很合适。所以……是的，如果你有兴趣做一些绘画，释放你的创造力，看看这篇文章，它很酷。你的绘画之旅进展如何？进展得相当不错，实际上我……嗯……是的，我画得非常接近了，所以你知道，我基本上有一个我想画的照片列表，不是说我真的想描摹照片，但我只是想做一个草图，所以我正在努力完成它，我应该在……也许几个月内完成。哇，那太好了。所以你做的是照片写实绘画吗？不，它们旨在成为抽象的，但照片旨在成为绘画的
um you know as i said in the previous show um kind of getting more into drawing is like a hobby and things like that so this this fit well with that for me so uh yeah if you're interested in doing some drawing releasing your creative energy uh check out this article it's pretty cool how is your drawing journey going it's going pretty good actually i uh um yeah i've been i'm bringing pretty close so you know i'm drawing basically i have i have a list of photographs that i want to make drawings of like not i don't literally want to trace the photograph but i just want to do a sketch of it and so i'm kind of making my way through it and i should be done in you know maybe like a couple of months wow that's very good so you do like photorealistic drawing no they're they're meant to be abstract but the photograph's meant to be like an
灵感。所以……是的，我得给你看一些。好吧……也许我会把一张贴到博客上什么的。完全切题，是的。好吧，我的下一个链接是谷歌发布了“如何成为一名软件工程师”，但我认为这很有趣，因为很多人想在谷歌工作。所以人们经常谈论这个。网上有很多关于进入谷歌或不进入谷歌的文章。所以这是谷歌关于学术学习的建议，他们称之为学术学习。他们基本上浏览了，你知道，一些 Udacity 课程、Coursera 课程、MIT 面向对象编程课程的链接，
inspiration for the drawing so uh yeah i'll have to show you some okay uh maybe i'll post one to the to the blog or something totally on topic yeah right so my next link is google put out a how to become a software engineer but i thought this was kind of interesting because a lot of people would like to work at Google. And so people talk about that a lot. And there's a lot of online writing about getting into Google or not. And so this is Google's recommendation on academic learnings is what they call it. And they basically go through, you know, some links to Udacity courses, Coursera courses, MIT courses for object-oriented programming,
你知道，学习 C++、Java、Python、其他语言，如何测试，测试方法。就像我们在节目中谈论的很多东西，如何构建编译器，很多他们，你知道，我想，觉得对在那里工作的工程师很重要的东西……我很惊讶他们把学习人工智能作为主要内容。所以当我读到这个，读完并试图理解它时……嗯，首先，使用这个指南，勾选这个指南上的所有项目并不能保证
you know, learning C++, Java, Python, other languages, how to test, test methodologies. Like a lot of the stuff we talk about in this show, how to build compilers, a lot of things that they, you know, I guess, feel is important for engineers who work there to... i'm surprised they put learn artificial intelligence as like a staple so i when i read this like read through this and tried to understand it uh well first of all using the guide checking off all items on this guide does not guarantee
在谷歌找到工作。我认为诚实地说，勾选所有这些项目需要一辈子。是的。对吧。要真正学习这里面的每一项。然后，我想他们说的是，这些是你至少想要高水平熟悉的领域。而且，
a job at google i think legitimately honest checking off all these items would take a lifetime. Yeah. Right. To actually learn every single item on here. And then to be, I think what they're saying is like, these are the areas you want to at least to be high level familiar with. And,
你知道，其中不止一两个，你可能应该相当擅长。明白了。或者做其中的一些只是要做的事情。总之，我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。如果它仅仅包含很多指向好的 MOOC 的链接，那就很有趣了，这显然是本节目的词汇，大规模开放在线课程，免费的，没错，免费的课程供你学习。比如，我不知道这个，关于编译器、密码学、异构并行处理的课程……那会很酷，那会是 GPU，我们谈论过
you know, more than one or two of them, you probably should be pretty good at. Gotcha. Or do some of them are just things to do um anyways but we'll have the link in the show notes it is interesting if nothing more than it has a lot of links to good uh mooks word of the show apparently massively open online courses free that's right free courses for you to take like there's i didn't know this of course there of course on compilers cryptography uh heterogeneous parallel processing um that would be cool that would be uh gpus which we've talked
关于其中一种方式……总之，去看看吧。异构在这个语境下是什么意思？它只是意味着不是有很多相同的核心，而是你有不同的核心，它们有不同的专长。比如 GPU 在某些方面很擅长，而 CPU 在其他方面很擅长。因此，一个同时拥有两者的系统就是异构的。你必须分配工作，以便最好的部分在最好的东西上运行。明白了。这说得通。酷，伙计。非常酷。
about one of the ways um anyways so check it out what does heterogeneous mean in that context it just means instead of like lots of cores which are the same you have different cores which have different uh specialties. Like GPUs are good at some things versus a CPU is good at others. So therefore, a system with both is heterogeneous. And you have to divide the work so that the best parts run on the best things. Gotcha. That makes sense. Cool, man. Very cool.
那是一个很棒的资源。所以，是的，所以我最近看了这个。它叫 Docker，这是最后一条新闻。它很酷。基本上，所以想象一下，你知道，你构建了一些很酷的网站，比如用 Java 或什么东西，你让它在你的笔记本电脑上运行，你可以连接到，你知道，本地的 localhost 并访问你的网站，你有一个也在你的笔记本电脑上运行的数据库，一切都很酷，然后你，你知道，把你的代码移动到服务器上，它完全崩溃了。你说，好吧，发生了什么？你发现，哦，服务器运行的是不同版本的 Linux，服务器运行的是不同版本的数据库。
That's a great resource. So, yeah, so I checked this out recently. It's called Docker, and it's the final news story. It's pretty cool. Basically, so imagine, you know, you build some cool website, like in Java or something, and you get it running on your laptop, and you can connect to, you know, local your local host and visit your website and you have a database that's also running on your laptop and everything's pretty cool and then you you know take your code move it to the server and it totally blows up you say well what happened you find out oh the server is running a different version of Linux the server is running a different version of the database.
它运行的是不同版本的 Java，而那个版本不支持你的东西，诸如此类，对吧？这非常令人沮丧。所以 Python 前段时间有一个很酷的东西，现在仍然存在，但已经存在一段时间了，叫 VirtualEnv，它基本上就像一个目录里的 Python 环境。所以你可以有一个包含 Python 构建和一堆其他东西的目录，然后你可以说“virtualenv 在那个目录”，它会把你放进那个环境，它会冻结你的 Python 版本。Ruby 有 RVM，非常相似。
It's running a different version of Java, and that version doesn't support your thing, so on and so forth, right? And it's super frustrating. So Python had this pretty cool thing a while back, which still exists, but it's been around for a while, called VirtualEnv, which was basically like a Python environment in a directory. So you could have some directory that has a Python build in it and a bunch of other stuff in it, and then you could say virtualenv in the directory, and it would put you in that environment, and it would sort of freeze your version of Python. Ruby has RVM, which is very similar.
所以你可以，比如，现在当你把代码发送到服务器时，你也发送 Ruby 本身。所以你保证你在服务器上运行的 Ruby 和你在测试时在笔记本电脑上运行的 Ruby 是一样的，对吧？所以 Docker 把这个想法发挥到了极致。所以他们为一切都有容器。他们有，你知道，数据库容器。他们有，你知道，Ruby 容器、Python 容器，诸如此类。
So you can, like, now when you send your code to the server, you also send Ruby itself. And so you're guaranteeing that the Ruby you run on the server is the same Ruby you ran on your laptop when you're testing it, right? So Docker kind of takes that idea to the extreme. So they have containers for everything. They have like a database container. They have a, you know, Ruby container, Python container, so on and so forth.
当你构建你的应用程序时，你有点依赖这些容器，它也是一个容器，所以当你去数据库，当你去服务器运行你的应用程序时，你只需要告诉它：“看，我想要完全这些版本的 Java 和 Python 以及所有这些东西”，它会为你处理它。所以你最终在服务器上得到的是，你可能有一台服务器运行，你可能有一台计算机运行着 10 个不同的 Web 服务器。所以它有 10 个不同版本的 Java，10 个不同版本的 Python，诸如此类。Docker 管理所有这些，这样它们就不会相互冲突。每个人都得到了他们开发时完全相同的环境。所以这非常棒。
And you sort of depend on these containers when you build your application which is also a container so then when you go to the database when you go to the server to run your application you just tell it look i want exactly these versions of java and python and all that stuff and it handles it for you and so what you end up with on the server is you might have a server running, you might have a computer running like 10 different web servers on it. And so it has 10 different versions of Java, 10 different versions of Python, so on and so forth. And Docker kind of manages all of that so that they don't conflict with each other. And everyone gets exactly the environment that they had when they were developing. So it's pretty awesome.
它获得了很大的动力。曾经有一些类似的东西，但它们没有 100% 工作。而这基本上是第一个真正极其稳固的东西，所以它火了。一定要去看看。它非常棒。我以前没用过 Docker，但我……它现在成了所有的热点，我一直听到它。是的，它非常棒。嗯，老实说，我只做了最基本的，我在工作中使用它运行一些简单的内部东西……我没有在像
It's picked up a lot of steam. There was kind of like things that sort of hokey things that kind of did similar as this, but they didn't work 100%. And this kind of was the first thing that really was extremely solid, and so it took off. Definitely check it out. It's pretty awesome i have not used docker before but i it's become all the buzz i hear about it all the time now yeah it's pretty sweet um i to be honest i've only done kind of the bare minimal like i'm running some simple internal stuff at work on it um i haven't used it in like a
繁重的生产环境中使用它，但它确实做了我想要它做的事情，这非常酷。不错。好吧，现在是本期图书时间，本周我们有一位特别嘉宾，但首先……这不适用于特别嘉宾采访，我们有史以来的第一次采访。祝贺我们。但我提醒大家，我们仍然有 Audible 30 天免费，我想是一本书的免费试用。所以如果你想看看，你可以去 www.audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。
heavy production environment but it did exactly what i wanted it to do which is which is pretty cool nice well it's time for book of the show and this week we have a special guest but first uh this won't be applicable to the special guest interview, our first ever interview. Congratulations to us. But I want to remind people that we still have our Audible 30-day free, I guess one book free trial going on. So if you want to check that out, you can go to www.audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown.
看看一些书。我们通常，每期节目都提供，至少我提供很棒的科幻和奇幻推荐，Jason 通常走高尚路线，提供一些让你成为更好的人的书……但是的，总之，你可以去看看 audible trial.com/programmingthrowdown。但本周我们有对 John Hargrave 爵士的特别采访。没错。正如 Patrick 所说，这是我们的首场采访。我们实际上有 John Hargrave 爵士在这里谈论他的书《Mind Hacking》。
Check out some books. We typically, every show offer, at least I offer awesome science fiction and fantasy recommendations jason typically takes the high road and offers uh something to make you a better person um but yeah anyways so you can check that out audible trial.com programming throwdown um but this week we have a special interview with sir John Hargrave. That's right. As Patrick said, it's our inaugural interview. And we actually have Sir John Hargrave here to talk about his book, Mind Hacking.
我看了一下，它非常酷。它基本上是……你肯定会比我总结得更好，但从我浏览一遍来看，它看起来像是一本关于我们所有人如何尝试打开我们的思维，更有创造力，更勤奋地处理项目，坚持到底等等的书。所以我很兴奋能读完它。我读了一半了。是的，那太好了，谢谢你邀请我。我一直
And I took a look at it and it's pretty cool. It's basically, and you definitely do a better summary than I would, but from just from going through making a pass at it, it looked like it like sort of a book about how all of us can try to sort of open up our mind, be more creative, tackle projects a little bit more diligence and follow through and things like that. And so I'm excited to finish it. I'm about halfway through. Yeah, that's great great thanks for having me on i've been sitting
坐在后台听整个节目，等待我的环节，所以能参加节目感觉很好。顺便说一句，那里的开胃菜很棒。酷，那些能量的噼啪声。《Mind Hacking》完全是关于重新编程你的思维，我很高兴能参加你们的节目，因为《Mind Hacking》真的是你能学习的最伟大的编程语言，因为你的思维是你所做一切的背后。所以在书中，我们谈论了很多关于调试你的思维。那些阻碍你的东西，然后重新编程那些想法，就像重新编程计算机一样，真正帮助你不仅实现你的目标，而且感觉良好并改善你的生活。酷。我知道很多听这个节目的人，他们要么是第一次作为大学努力或高中后期努力的一部分进入编程和这类事情，要么是那些，你知道，选择了不同职业的人，我们见过从化学工程到以制造光剑为生的人，
here in the background for the entire show waiting for my segment so it's good to be on great hors d'oeuvres back there by the way cool those crackles of energy mind hacking is all about reprogramming your mind and i'm excited to be on your show because mind hacking is really the greatest programming language you can learn because your mind is behind everything you do. So in the book, we talk a lot about debugging your mind. that hold you back, but then reprogramming those thoughts, like reprogramming a computer to really help you not only achieve your goals, but to feel great and improve your life. Cool. I know a lot of the people who are listening to the show, they're either getting into programming and these kinds of things for the first time as part of a you know a college endeavor or a late high school endeavor or they are people who you know kind of picked picked a different profession we've seen everything from chemical engineering to someone who manufactures lightsabers for a living
他们只是把编程作为一种爱好开始，他们想把它提升到一个新的水平，他们想用它做一些更重要或更大的事情，或者只是学习和增强他们的知识体系。所以我认为这本书对此非常酷。是的，这也是我的背景。你知道，我是在个人电脑开始起飞的时候长大的。在书的开头，我谈论了很多我第一次编程课的经历。而且，你知道，在我第一门编程课的学期结束时，你知道在我第一门编程课的学期结束时……
and they just programming started off as a hobby and they want to take it to the next level and they want to do something something more important with it or bigger with it or just learn and enhance their body of knowledge. And so I think this book is pretty cool for that. Yeah, and that's my background too. You know, I came of age just as personal computers were starting to take off. And in the beginning of the book, I talk a lot about my experiences with my first programming classes. And, you know, by the end of the semester of my first programming class, you know by the end of the semester of my my first programming
他们刚开始把编程当作一种爱好，现在想把它提升到一个新的水平，想用它做一些更重要或更宏大的事情，或者仅仅是想学习并扩展自己的知识体系。所以我认为这本书在这方面非常棒。是的，这也是我的背景。你知道，我成年的时候，个人电脑正开始兴起。在书的开头，我谈了很多关于我第一次上编程课的经历。你知道，在我第一门编程课的学期末，你知道，在我第一门编程课的学期末
class i was teaching the teachers and i talk a lot about you know exploring things like a semi legal phone switching software but i got involved with it let you make free phone calls and just that sense of playfulness and curiosity and fun that really characterized the early personal computing revolution. So I can really relate to your audience. And I love that sense of learning something new and then also of exploration of what computers can do. And that's really that same sense of curiosity and fun that I tried to bring to this mind hacking concept, approaching our minds with that same sense of curiosity. Cool, cool. Yeah, I thought that your background definitely is worth, you know, having a discussion on. I mean, I was absolutely, I read the book first, actually,
我当时在教老师们，我谈了很多关于探索诸如半合法电话交换软件之类的事情，但我参与其中，它让你能免费打电话，那种在个人计算革命早期所特有的顽皮、好奇和乐趣。所以我真的能和你的听众产生共鸣。我喜欢那种学习新东西的感觉，也喜欢探索计算机能做什么。这和我试图带入这种“思维黑客”概念的、以同样的好奇心去接近我们大脑的乐趣和好奇心是一样的。酷，酷。是的，我觉得你的背景绝对值得我们讨论一下。我的意思是，我绝对是先读了这本书，实际上，
I went through and then i went in and kind of dug in it was absolutely fascinating the sort of different things that you've been involved in it was it was really quite interesting um how you've been sort of in the entertainment field and then in the entrepreneurial field and then helping other people um you know motivating other people to to take advances and the whole thing has just been fascinating kind of walk us through sort of the path that got you to to writing this book well i was born on a small farm in tennessee uh as as you said uh you know i started out as a. So I started out as a developer early in my career. I started out with a company that's still around called ZDNet.com, one of the biggest
我通读了一遍，然后深入研究了一下，你所参与的各种事情绝对令人着迷，这真的非常有趣，嗯，你是如何进入娱乐领域，然后进入创业领域，然后帮助其他人，你知道，激励其他人去取得进步，这一切都太迷人了，请带我们了解一下你写这本书的历程。嗯，我出生在田纳西州的一个小农场，正如你所说，我最初是一名开发人员。我职业生涯早期是在一家至今仍然存在的公司，叫 ZDNet.com，是最大的
computing sites out there. And it really just gave me, it was a fantastic time because it was as the internet was just starting to take off. And those years were really magical. That was really just a moment in history. And it just cemented my love for technology and all things geeky and ran a humor site called Zugg.com for many years and also had this business, Media Shower. And so as the years went on, Media Shower continued to grow. And I now run that full time. We're a content marketing company.
计算网站之一。那真是一段美妙的时光，因为那时互联网才刚刚开始腾飞。那些年真的很神奇。那确实是历史上的一个时刻。它巩固了我对技术和所有极客事物的热爱，我经营了一个名为 Zugg.com 的幽默网站很多年，还拥有这家名为 Media Shower 的公司。随着岁月的流逝，Media Shower 不断壮大。我现在全职经营它。我们是一家内容营销公司。
But along the way, I really learned being an entrepreneur and also wrestling with my own demons and working toward my own goals that my biggest enemy was my mind. It was the thing that held me back most often. And I say in the book, your mind can be your greatest friend and also your worst enemy. And what we need, I am convinced as a society, is tools to learn how to manage our own minds. Think of all the effort we put into educating people about math and science and reading and writing, but we don't talk about that most basic skill of learning how to manage your own mind. So that's really become my passion is sharing with people, here are some of the hacks or the tricks that I learned to manage my own mind and get to where I am today. And I want to help them do the same.
但在这一过程中，我真正学到的是，作为一名企业家，同时还要与自己的心魔作斗争并努力实现自己的目标，我最大的敌人就是我的大脑。它往往是阻碍我前进的东西。我在书中说过，你的大脑既可以是最好的朋友，也可以是最坏的敌人。我深信，作为一个社会，我们需要的是学习如何管理我们大脑的工具。想想我们在教育人们数学、科学、阅读和写作上投入了多少努力，但我们却不谈论学习如何管理自己大脑这一最基本的技能。所以，分享我学会的那些管理大脑并达到今天成就的技巧或窍门，已经真正成为了我的热情所在。我想帮助他们也做到这一点。
Cool. I actually, I was one of those people early in life where I didn't really care about history or in history classes or anything like that. And i didn't i read a lot of you know sort of geeky things a lot of kind of fiction books but i didn't read a lot of self-help books or or anything like that and at some point i've i kind of realized i was learning a lot of things the hard way and uh just really starting from scratch on things. And over time, especially if you have to go and get an advanced degree and you have to publish papers and things like that, you realize that it's a lot easier to build on the shoulders of giants, so to speak, right? So that's when I started really getting into, you know, digesting a lot of information, reading a lot of information about people who are writing about their experiences, their history,
酷。实际上，我早年是那种对历史或历史课之类的事情不太关心的人。我读了很多极客的东西，很多小说，但我没读过多少自助书籍之类的东西。在某个时候，我意识到我是在用困难的方式学习很多东西，而且在很多事情上都是从零开始。随着时间的推移，特别是如果你必须去攻读高级学位，必须发表论文之类的，你就会意识到，站在巨人的肩膀上要容易得多，对吧？所以，那时我开始真正投入到消化大量信息中，阅读大量关于人们撰写他们经历、历史的信息，
and also sort of how they can sort of what they've learned in some kind of specialty. Right. So one of my favorite books I keep going back to in the show is, is the dummies guide to negotiation and uh i read that just because i was uh um was curious what a dummies book was and i'd always been making fun of them for for you know the label they put in and everything like that but then i ended up being just one of the best books i've ever read in my whole life and um so now i'm kind of a big fan of people who have gone through very interesting, especially very eclectic experiences, sort of learning from them and building on top of that. And so I think
以及他们如何在某种专业领域学到了什么。对。所以我在节目中经常提到的我最喜欢的书之一是《傻瓜谈判指南》，我读它只是因为我好奇“傻瓜书”是什么，我一直拿它们开玩笑，因为它们贴的标签之类的，但后来它最终成了我一生中读过的最好的书之一。所以现在我成了那些经历过非常有趣、特别是非常不拘一格的经历的人的忠实粉丝，从他们身上学习并在此基础上进行构建。所以我认为
this is one of those books that can really help people. Thanks. Yeah, I'm a fan of the For Dummies books too. DOS For Dummies was the first, I mean, that was the first For Dummies book. That was the first one I owned. DOS was, of course, course the original pc operating system and it was confusing if you didn't have much of a technology background and what they did that was brilliant was they just pulled in humor and they made it very accessible you know they they explained it in plain english and it was funny and it had cartoons in it and lots of eye candy. And that's been basically the formula they've used for that franchising empire. And it is relevant because that's very much what we've tried to do with mind hacking is take this very kind of arcane sort of philosophical concept of your mind
这是能真正帮助人们的书之一。谢谢。是的，我也是《傻瓜》系列书的粉丝。《DOS 傻瓜书》是第一本，我的意思是，那是第一本《傻瓜》书。那是我拥有的第一本。DOS 当然是最初的个人电脑操作系统，如果你没有太多的技术背景，它会让人困惑，而他们做得非常出色的一点是，他们融入了幽默，使它变得非常容易理解，你知道，他们用通俗易懂的英语解释，它很有趣，里面有卡通画和很多吸引眼球的东西。这基本上就是他们用于那个特许经营帝国的公式。这很有意义，因为这正是我们在“思维黑客”中尝试做的事情，即采用这种非常深奥的关于你的大脑的哲学概念
and managing your mind, but put lots of humor and put lots of real life examples around it. We tell lots of stories of great, you know, great geeks throughout history, great technological innovations, and how we can use those to manage our own minds. So I'm glad you enjoyed it. Thank you for that, Jason. Yes. So what part from the point, just kind of following the history of the book, from the point where, you know, you started having this downward spiral with addiction to where the Secret Service comes knocking on your door to where you managed to beat those demons and where, you know, in your own words, you hack your mind and you're able to sort of you know get better control of yourself and your your family and your destiny
以及管理你的大脑，但加入了很多幽默和现实生活中的例子。我们讲述了历史上许多伟大的极客、伟大的技术创新的故事，以及我们如何利用这些来管理我们自己的大脑。所以我很高兴你喜欢它。谢谢你，杰森。是的。那么，从书的历史来看，从你开始陷入成瘾的恶性循环，到特勤局敲你的门，再到你设法战胜那些心魔，用你自己的话说，你“黑”进了你的大脑，并能够更好地控制自己、你的家庭和你的命运，
all the way up to running this company so at what point did you decide you know i'm going to write a self-help book this is always one of these things that interests me like when do programming language inventors decide you know screw it i'm not going to use C++ anymore. I'm going to invent my own language. It's a massive undertaking. And I feel like in the case of programming language inventors, a lot of them are the kind of people that they just don't settle for what's out there. They don't want to use tools that are inferior. And at some point they say, you know, this is worth the five year investment it's going to make for me to spin up this language and generate support. So at what
一直到经营这家公司，那么你在什么时候决定写一本自助书的？这总是让我感兴趣的事情之一，比如编程语言的发明者什么时候决定“去他的，我再也不用 C++ 了。我要发明我自己的语言。”这是一个巨大的工程。我觉得在编程语言发明者的情况下，他们中的许多人是那种不满足于现有事物的人。他们不想使用劣质的工具。在某个时候，他们会说，你知道，为了启动这种语言并产生支持，这值得我投入五年的时间。那么在什么
point for you did it sort of click and you said, okay, I'm going to write this book and invest this time? It's a great question. And I guess the best answer I can give is that I heard once someone say, you should only write a book if you can't help not writing the book. So in other words, if there is a spontaneous expression that rises up within you that says you must write this book, that's a really good reason to write a book. And I think the same is true when you're developing a programming language or you're doing any kind of great creative work that there is a drive, there's a passion that springs up from within you and you just know this is what I have to do.
时候对你来说它产生了共鸣，你决定，好吧，我要写这本书并投入这些时间？这是一个很好的问题。我想我能给出的最好答案是，我曾经听到有人说，只有当你无法不写这本书时，你才应该写书。换句话说，如果内心有一种自发的表达，说你必须写这本书，那这就是写书的一个非常好的理由。我认为当你开发一种编程语言或做任何伟大的创造性工作时也是如此，有一种动力，一种从你内心涌出的热情，你只是知道这就是我必须做的事情。
This is the next thing that I've really got to be involved with. How did you guys decide to do this podcast? You know, there was something in you that said, we've got to do this podcast. There was something in you that said, we've got to do this podcast. And you do it and you put your heart and your passion into it. And eventually it starts to click with people. And that's how we move these things forward. So I think that's the quick answer to your question. There's a passion. There's's an energy there's an excitement that should drive us to do these these great things and when we feel it we got to act on it gotcha so along those lines and i haven't read the entire book yet so i feel like this might be in one of those areas of the
这是我真正必须参与的下一件事。你们是怎么决定做这个播客的？你知道，你内心有什么东西说，我们必须做这个播客。你内心有什么东西说，我们必须做这个播客。你做了，并把你的心和热情投入其中。最终它开始与人们产生共鸣。这就是我们推动这些事情前进的方式。所以我认为这是对你问题的简短回答。有一种热情。有一种能量，有一种兴奋，应该驱动我们去做这些伟大的事情，当我们感觉到它时，我们就必须采取行动。明白了，那么沿着这些思路，我还没有读完整本书，所以我感觉这可能是在
book that i haven't read near the end but how do you where does the sustainability come from i mean i feel like i have a million different side projects and of that you know programming down throw down is among the few that where the sustainability is there and where it's really kind of gotten off the chopping block and it's become kind of a real thing that we have going here but so many projects, kind of they just the momentum dies out, the idea fizzles out. And just there's there's plenty of people out there can relate to this, where they have this great idea, they have that energy. And then after a few weeks, it's gone, or after the fun part is done, it's gone, and they can't kind of execute. So how does mind hacking help with that part of it?
我还没读到的书的结尾部分，但可持续性从何而来？我的意思是，我觉得我有一百万个不同的副项目，其中“编程抛下”（Programming Throwdown）是少数几个具有可持续性、真正摆脱了困境并成为我们正在进行的真正事业的项目之一。但太多的项目，它们的动力消失了，想法破灭了。有很多对此有共鸣的人，他们有这个伟大的想法，他们有那种能量。然后几周后，它就消失了，或者在有趣的部分结束后，它就消失了，他们无法执行。那么“思维黑客”在这方面有什么帮助吗？
Yeah, so in the end of the book, which you'll get to as soon as we finish this podcast tonight, we talk about the ability to act. In other words, once you kind of debug your mind, you clarify your thinking, you plan, you kind of reprogram your mind with these new values and these new goals. Well, then how do you make that happen? How do you bring it out into the world? And what you're asking is, how do you persist? So how do you continue to do it? And there's a whole chapter on this where we talk about breaking up your goals into sub goals. We have an acronym called LASER, which talks about the best kinds of goals and how to make those repeatable and something that you can do day after day to really start to make progress toward those
是的，在书的结尾，也就是我们今晚录完这个播客后你就会读到的地方，我们谈到了行动的能力。换句话说，一旦你调试了你的大脑，理清了你的思路，制定了计划，用这些新的价值观和新的目标重新编程你的大脑。那么，你如何实现它呢？你如何把它带到世界上？你问的是，你如何坚持下去？书中有一整章专门讨论这个问题，我们谈到了将你的目标分解为子目标。我们有一个缩写词叫 LASER，它讨论了最好的目标类型，以及如何使它们可重复，以及你可以日复一日地做些什么来真正开始朝着这些目标取得进展。
goals. But what generally happens is people have negative loops that kind of go on in their mind that sort of drain their mental energy. And because that's happening, they lose momentum in continuing to push on those projects. So for example, you might be very excited about this new programming project on day one. And then day three, other concerns and worries start seeping in.
但通常发生的情况是，人们在大脑中进行着负面循环，这会消耗他们的精神能量。因为这种情况正在发生，他们在继续推进这些项目时失去了动力。例如，你可能在第一天对这个新的编程项目非常兴奋。然后到了第三天，其他的担忧和焦虑开始渗入。
We call these your negative thought loops or your negative habits. And then that starts to drain the energy that you want to put into this main project. cut off those sort of energy leaks from your thinking and reprogram those negative loops, you'll have more energy to keep putting into these projects that you're passionate about and make some real progress. Gotcha. Yeah. I feel like a lot of it, and this is just looking back empirically at the things that I've done, and Patrick, maybe you can chime in one way or the other, whether you agree with this, is a lot of it for me has been about the philosophy. Like, the reason why programming throwdown is really interesting to me is that I've always wanted to teach, and I was torn between becoming a professor and going into industry, and I feel
我们称这些为你的负面思维循环或负面习惯。然后这开始消耗你想投入到这个主要项目中的能量。切断那些思维中的能量泄漏并重新编程那些负面循环，你就会有更多的精力继续投入到你热衷的这些项目中，并取得真正的进展。明白了。是的，我觉得很大程度上，这只是凭经验回顾我所做的事情，帕特里克，也许你可以附和一下，无论你是否同意这一点，对我来说很大程度上是关于哲学。比如，为什么“编程抛下”对我来说非常有趣，是因为我一直想教书，我在成为教授和进入工业界之间徘徊，我觉得
like this was a way to sort of get the best of both worlds to kind of teach myself and teach other people about programming and then also to kind of have have an industry job and uh i think that because there's sort of a philosophy philosophical reason behind it that's what sort of keeps it going when you're in i guess as you say one of these negative loops where you have to spend you know four hours putting together the show and then at the end the notes uh you know your your computer crashes and you lose all your notes you have to spend another four hours redoing it when those things happen it's this sort of philosophy that sort of is that positive light that keeps shining,
这是一种两全其美的方式，既可以教自己，也可以教别人编程，同时还能有一份工业界的工作。我认为因为背后有一种哲学原因，这就是当你在我所说的这些负面循环之一中时，让你坚持下去的原因，比如你必须花四个小时来整理节目，然后在最后，笔记……你知道，你的电脑崩溃了，你丢失了所有笔记，你必须再花四个小时重做。当这些事情发生时，正是这种哲学，那种持续闪耀的正能量，让你度过那些不太有趣的部分。
that keeps you going through the parts that aren't very fun. Yeah, you're helping people, right? And that's, I think, what you're saying is that you're providing a real value, a service with this podcast. And in the book, we talk about collaboration and we talk about, you know, that's another great way of staying focused on these goals is collaborating or thinking about what can I give back and how can I help people and how can I work with people to do something that's greater than myself. Yeah, or even if it is more self-centered, like your goal is to make an awesome to-do list website. That's often one thing that we tell people when they ask uh well you know what's the first thing i can build um even if that is your goal it's uh it's
是的，你在帮助人们，对吧？我认为这就是你所说的，你正在通过这个播客提供真正的价值和服务。在书中，我们谈到了协作，我们谈到了，你知道，这是保持专注于这些目标的另一种好方法，那就是协作，或者思考我能回馈什么，我如何能帮助人们，以及我如何能与人们合作去做一些比我自己更伟大的事情。是的，或者即使它更以自我为中心，比如你的目标是制作一个很棒的待办事项网站。当人们问“我能做的第一件事是什么”时，我们经常告诉他们这一点，即使那是你的目标，
good to sort of stay focused on that like instead of instead of saying i'm going to make the the fastest uh you know game engine i can and then you end up with you know a small piece of a game engine if the goal is sort of like very abstract and kind of philosophical, you can try to then you're fine sort of maybe cutting corners here and there or doing the not so pretty solution or things like that. Because because the goal is something that's that's kind of much more high level. Yeah. In the book, there's there's a whole section about just barely good enough, right? JBGE. So the object is to get code or to get projects that are just barely good enough. It's the same concept as kind of agile development.
保持专注也是好的，而不是说“我要制作我能做的最快的游戏引擎”，然后你最终只得到了游戏引擎的一小部分。如果目标是抽象和哲学化的，你可能会在某些地方走捷径，或者做不那么漂亮的解决方案之类的。因为目标是更高层次的东西。是的。在书中，有一整节关于“刚好够好”（JBGE）的内容。所以目标是获得刚好够好的代码或项目。这和敏捷开发的概念是一样的。
We want to just get something out. So many of us suffer from perfectionism. We suffer from wanting everything to be perfect before we can feel like it's worthy of being released. But if we can adopt an attitude of I just want to move the ball forward, I want to take a small step today toward this goal. I want to just get something produced and get it live and get it out there. And then I can iterate. Right. I can continue to improve based on feedback that I receive. And that's why I would say to anybody listening to this podcast, it's a lot of work to produce content. And what Jason
我们只想把东西做出来。我们许多人都患有完美主义。我们受困于在觉得它值得发布之前，想要一切都完美。但如果我们能采取一种“我只想推动事情向前发展”的态度，我今天想朝着这个目标迈出一小步。我只想生产出一些东西，让它上线，让它发布出去。然后我可以迭代。对。我可以根据我收到的反馈继续改进。这就是为什么我会对任何收听这个播客的人说，制作内容是一项艰苦的工作。而杰森
and Patrick do is it takes a lot of time for, you know, this hour that you're listening to it here, many hours are going on behind the scenes. So the best thing you can do for any of your favorite content producers is thank them, is just give them positive feedback. When you do that, it really is incredibly motivating. And in many ways, it's like the only reward that you're really getting. You're not getting paid for it. Read all those iTunes reviews, at least the positive ones anyways. Yeah, definitely.
和帕特里克所做的，需要花费很多时间，你知道，你在这里听到的这一小时，幕后有很多小时的工作。所以你能为你最喜欢的任何内容创作者做的最好的事情就是感谢他们，就是给他们积极的反馈。当你这样做时，它真的非常令人鼓舞。在很多方面，这是你真正得到的唯一回报。你没有因此得到报酬。阅读所有那些 iTunes 评论，至少是积极的那些。是的，绝对。
Cool. Patrick, do you have any questions? I was just going to comment. The minimally viable product, Lean Startup, is the other idea that goes along with what we're talking about. And, The Lean Startup. But yeah, that's a fantastic book. It's one that a lot of people keep going back to. And at least here, it always seems like everyone's kind of read that book. So that's always a good sign. The Lean Startup is one of the foundational books behind our company, Media Shower. We talk about it in employee training whenever we bring on new folks. And I think it's a fantastic book that really does drive home that point of it's much better to get something live than to get it perfect. Just get it done.
酷。帕特里克，你有什么问题吗？我只是想评论一下。最小可行性产品，“精益创业”，是与我们正在谈论的内容相伴的另一个想法。而且，《精益创业》。但是的，那是一本很棒的书。它是很多人不断回看的书。至少在这里，每个人似乎都读过那本书。所以这总是一个好迹象。《精益创业》是我们公司 Media Shower 的基础书籍之一。每当我们有新人加入时，我们都会在员工培训中谈论它。我认为这是一本非常棒的书，它确实强化了“让东西上线比让它完美更重要”的观点。只要把它做出来。
Don't get it perfect. But also constantly improve, constantly iterate on it, and just keep chipping away and making your product better and better. Yeah, I feel like there's this misconception that the minimally viable product means you're not working hard enough. But it's really that you're working so hard and so fast that you can change directions quickly. And it's more that you're still running, but not in a straight line. You're constantly pivoting as you learn more and as you iterate. And that's just supremely important. Yeah, the misnomer about, I say in the book, in just barely good enough is that, as you said, it's pretty low quality.
不要追求完美。但也要不断改进，不断迭代，不断打磨，让你的产品越来越好。是的，我觉得有一种误解，认为最小可行性产品意味着你工作不够努力。但实际上，这意味着你工作得如此努力和迅速，以至于你可以快速改变方向。这更多的是你仍在奔跑，但不是直线奔跑。随着你的学习和迭代，你不断地进行调整。这极其重要。是的，我在书中说，关于“刚好够好”的误称是，正如你所说，它的质量相当低。
It's just barely good enough. It's not very good, but the truth is, it's actually the best possible because you get the most accomplished with the minimum amount of effort. So from an efficiency standpoint or from an elegant standpoint, it is the most efficient, best solution. And it's self-recognizing that no strategy survives first contact with the enemy, right? So you're trying to make something for someone else, and when you finally put something out there, it won't be right.
它只是刚好够好。它不是很好，但事实是，它实际上是最好的，因为你用最少的努力完成了最多的事情。所以从效率的角度或优雅的角度来看，它是最高效、最好的解决方案。而且它自我承认，没有战略能在与敌人的第一次接触中幸存，对吧？所以你试图为别人制造东西，当你最终把它发布出去时，它不会是正确的。
Yeah, that's right. At the first time anyway. Yeah, that's a great point. You need to get that feedback. Yeah, thanks a lot for coming on the show. The book is fascinating. I'm going to read the other half right now. Actually, by the time you guys listen to this, I would have to read the other half right now actually by the time
是的，那是对的。至少第一次不是。是的，这是一个很好的观点。你需要得到那个反馈。是的，非常感谢你来到节目中。这本书很迷人。我现在要读剩下的那一半。实际上，当你们听到这个的时候，我必须现在就读剩下的那一半，实际上当
you guys listen to this i would have already read the other half and you haven't even started yet so uh you guys out there have to have to catch up cool um excellent sir john hargrave it was great having you on the show on our book of this show and our also first interview ever on Programming Throwdown. So thank you for bearing with us while we had our inaugural interview and got everything going here. It was my pleasure. And I'm going to go back off to the green room now. It's off to the right, down the hall to the right.
你们听到这个的时候，我已经读完了剩下的那一半，而你们甚至还没开始。所以你们这些家伙必须赶上。酷，嗯，非常棒，约翰·哈格雷夫，很高兴你能参加我们的节目，这是我们节目的书，也是“编程抛下”有史以来的第一次采访。所以感谢你在我们进行首次采访并让一切顺利进行时对我们的包容。这是我的荣幸。我现在要回到休息室了。就在右边，走廊右转。
Yeah, that's right. The long hallway just past the mansion, the stables and the helicopter pad. All right. Thanks, guys. All right. Thanks a lot. Have a good one. hallway just uh past the mansion the stables and the helicopter pad all right thanks guys all right thanks a lot have a good one yeah time for tool of the show to to the tool of the show so um i don't think we talked about this one in our unix commands um show but even if we probably did but it's awesome enough to use again that's right if you If you're using Baboon, which you should be after our last show on Windows, or you are running Mac or Linux, you have access to this amazing utility. And if you're ever using CP, you probably should be using RS, which you alias to rsync.
是的，没错。就在豪宅、马厩和直升机停机坪之后的那条长走廊。好的，谢谢你们。好的，非常感谢。祝你们过得愉快。走廊就在豪宅、马厩和直升机停机坪之后。好的，谢谢你们。好的，非常感谢。祝你们过得愉快。是的，是时候介绍“本期工具”了。本期工具。所以，嗯，我不认为我们在我们的 Unix 命令节目中谈论过这个，但即使我们可能谈过，它也足够棒，值得再次使用。没错，如果你正在使用 Baboon，你应该在我们关于 Windows 的上一期节目之后使用它，或者你正在运行 Mac 或 Linux，你就有权使用这个惊人的实用程序。如果你曾经使用 CP，你可能应该使用 RS，你将其别名为 rsync。
So rsync is basically cp on steroids so you know first of all any command cp can do rs can do just naturally um it's faster um it also well in certain cases it's faster it's not always faster but uh um also it has some pretty awesome capabilities. So if you do rsync-raz, then what it will do is it will look at the destination and look at the source and only copy what's changed. So that's pretty cool if you're copying to a server and maybe you're doing it every day or something like that. Definitely use rsync, right? You don't want to waste all that bandwidth.
所以 rsync 基本上是增强版的 cp，所以你知道首先，任何 cp 能做的命令，rs 都能自然地做到，它更快，嗯，在某些情况下它更快，它并不总是更快，但它也有一些非常棒的功能。所以如果你执行 rsync-raz，它会查看目标和源，并且只复制更改的内容。所以如果你要复制到服务器，也许你每天都在做这件事，这很酷。一定要使用 rsync，对吧？你不想浪费所有那些带宽。
It has a number of other really cool features. It can do one-way synchronization. It can do clobbering or no clobbering, which means if you delete something on the source, it will delete it on the destination, so on and so forth. Basically, it has a ton of functionality like this you know you can do it across computers like you can actually rsync to an ssh endpoint you don't have to rsync just from one directory to the other um i think some versions can even rsync to ftp servers like it's kind of crazy but i know it can do ssh um and uh yeah i use it all the time I think it's pretty great rsync yeah all one word rsnyc yeah my tool of the show is not a software tool
它还有许多其他非常酷的功能。它可以进行单向同步。它可以进行覆盖或不覆盖，这意味着如果你删除了源上的东西，它也会删除目标上的东西，等等。基本上，它有大量这样的功能，你可以在计算机之间进行操作，比如你可以实际 rsync 到 ssh 端点，你不必只从一个目录 rsync 到另一个目录，我想有些版本甚至可以 rsync 到 ftp 服务器，这有点疯狂，但我知道它可以做 ssh，而且我一直都在使用它，我认为它非常棒。rsync，是的，一个词，rsync。是的，我的本期工具不是软件工具。
it is a multimeter multimeter depending on I was wondering if like you're gonna say oh this is an android app or ios app nope this is a good old-fashioned lives in your toolbox electrical measuring device nice i have one behind me but i won't get it out do you oh well it won't come we won't be able to see it in the audio version anyways so um so the reason why this is my tool of the show is because although we're software engineers uh it is very useful sometimes. Wow, that was a lot of caveats. I find it to be useful to have and know how to use a multimeter.
它是一个万用表，取决于……我还在想你是不是要说“这是一个安卓应用或 iOS 应用”，不，这是一个老式的、放在你的工具箱里的电气测量设备。不错，我身后有一个，但我不会拿出来。你有吗？好吧，我们无论如何也无法在音频版本中看到它。所以，我选择这个作为本期工具的原因是，虽然我们是软件工程师，但它有时非常有用。哇，那真是太多的警告了。我发现拥有并知道如何使用万用表很有用。
I'm going to look it up. No, I looked it up. It's actually both, which is why I'm saying both. I asked Google, define multimeter. I switch back and forth on how I say it. A multimeter, if i switch back and forth on how i say it so um anyways a multimeter it you know allows you it's a if you don't know it's a physical object which has two wires coming out of it and one's red one's black typically and allows you to measure voltage uh resistance sometimes um other it's called you know a multimeter because it multiple different things and you're able to
我要查一下。不，我查过了。实际上两者都有，这就是为什么我说两者。我问谷歌，定义万用表。我在我怎么说它之间来回切换。万用表，如果我在我怎么说它之间来回切换。所以，无论如何，万用表，它允许你……如果你不知道，它是一个物理物体，有两根电线从它出来，通常一根是红色的，一根是黑色的，允许你测量电压、电阻，有时还有其他……它被称为万用表，因为它测量多种不同的东西，你能够
for instance if you have like around the house I have them just to measure like is this battery dead or not and you can buy those specific battery testers or you can just measure the voltage with your multimeter also I use it for like doing conductivity testing like um if i have like a wire like a you know be really careful i shouldn't recommend what i do with it because if you're doing electrical stuff around your house be really safe and make sure the power is off yeah i mean but like your fuse box know what your fuse box is yes but but yes i use it a lot around the house um but also at work i do low level uh programming so often i have hardware and it's important for me to be able to tell, like, various voltages on my development boards that we have.
例如，如果你在家里，我用它们只是为了测量电池是否没电，你可以买那些专门的电池测试仪，或者你可以只用你的万用表测量电压。我也用它进行导电性测试，比如，如果我有一根电线，比如，你知道，要非常小心，我不应该推荐我用它做什么，因为如果你在家里做电气工作，要非常安全，并确保电源已关闭。是的，我的意思是，但比如你的保险丝盒，知道你的保险丝盒是什么。是的，但是的，我在家里经常使用它，但在工作中我也做底层编程，所以我经常有硬件，能够判断比如我的开发板上的各种电压对我来说很重要。
And so I need to be able to tell, is, you know, something on or off? What's the power draw in a given region of the board? These kinds of things. And so I find this tool indispensable. And it really makes people you work with who are in other disciplines, you know, appreciate that you know more than just your niche. So a lot of people think, you know, software engineers just know software. And then when you kind of know how to use tools properly, then they, you know, kind of gives you a little bit more respect.
所以我需要能够判断，某样东西是开还是关？板子特定区域的功耗是多少？这些事情。所以我发现这个工具不可或缺。它确实让你在其他学科工作的同事欣赏你不仅仅了解你的利基领域。所以很多人认为，你知道，软件工程师只懂软件。然后当你正确地使用工具时，他们会给你多一点尊重。
Yeah, you definitely get some street cred. Yeah. All the cool kids are using them. Yeah, all the cool kids are using multimeters. Ah cool kids using multimeters ah yes so cool that's my tool of the week probably useless do you have any do you have any so actually i was wondering to ask you this a little bit of side note but if i was to get any of these sort of starter kits like a beagle board or raspberry pi uh nerd kit uh like like which of these should I get? As somebody who knows virtually nothing about this stuff.
是的，你绝对会获得一些街头信誉。是的，所有酷孩子都在使用它们。是的，所有酷孩子都在使用万用表。啊，酷孩子使用万用表，啊，是的，太酷了。这是我的本周工具，可能没用。你有吗？实际上，我本来想问你这个，有点题外话，但如果我要买这些入门套件中的任何一个，比如 Beagle Board 或 Raspberry Pi，Nerd Kit，我应该买哪一个？作为一个对这些东西几乎一无所知的人。
Raspberry Pi and BeagleBone are kind of the same thing, in my opinion. They are different, but they're at the same level, which is they're small Linux computers. And so if you want to do both powerful Linux internet-y things and also be able to control
在我看来，Raspberry Pi 和 BeagleBone 是一回事。它们不同，但它们处于同一水平，即它们都是小型 Linux 计算机。所以如果你想既做强大的 Linux 互联网相关的事情，又能控制
hardware, they're really good. Do they have the I2C connector and all that stuff? Yeah, I think they have it brought out to a GPIO header, like a set of pins, so you can talk I2C to other devices. And then there's lots of libraries for doing that. Of course, personally, I find doing I2C in Linux to just be overcomplicated. People do do it, and there's libraries to help you do it.
硬件，它们真的很好。它们有 I2C 连接器和所有那些东西吗？是的，我想它们通过 GPIO 接头引出了它，就像一组引脚，所以你可以与其他设备进行 I2C 通信。而且有很多库可以做到这一点。当然，就我个人而言，我发现用 Linux 做 I2C 过于复杂。人们确实在做，而且有库可以帮助你做到这一点。
And if you were gonna develop something that you wanted to also have like displayed on your computer, for instance, or be a web server, that's the way to go. But if you're looking to just learn about hardware, because personally I like doing in my spare time what I don't do in my work time. Right.
如果你要开发一些你也想在电脑上显示的东西，或者做一个网络服务器，那就是最好的选择。但如果你只是想学习硬件，因为我个人喜欢在业余时间做我工作时间不做的事情。对。
And so like, if you do kind of that programming a lot, it may be lean more towards like something that's Arduino based because an Arduino isn't going to have an operating system. It's going to be much more just about the hardware. The programs are going to tend to be simpler. They won't be able to do as much per se, but they're going to be better at timing and controlling hardware because they're simpler things.
所以，如果你做那种编程很多，它可能更倾向于像 Arduino 那样的东西，因为 Arduino 不会有操作系统。它更多的是关于硬件。程序往往会更简单。它们本身不能做那么多事情，但它们在定时和控制硬件方面会更好，因为它们是更简单的东西。
And they'll also be cheaper typically. Gotcha. So that's the approach. Okay, so Arduino isduino is what you that's that's the approach i would take if you really are wanting to learn about like i2c devices spi devices um blinking leds that kind of stuff i feel like it's more straightforward to get there on an arduino than a raspberry pi okay cool good to know does arduino have like a wi-fi chip can you can you they do have one but it is pretty expensive okay got it but yeah like but then if i was going to do wi-fi something i'd probably i might go with like a raspberry pi because like wi-fi is complicated um ah okay right but like you could always start on an arduino talk to like if you're going to talk
而且它们通常也会更便宜。明白了。所以这就是方法。好的，所以 Arduino 是你……这就是我会采取的方法，如果你真的想学习 I2C 设备、SPI 设备、闪烁 LED 之类的东西，我觉得在 Arduino 上比在 Raspberry Pi 上更容易实现。好的，酷，很高兴知道。Arduino 有 Wi-Fi 芯片吗？你可以……它们确实有一个，但相当昂贵。好的，明白了。但如果我要做 Wi-Fi 的东西，我可能会选择 Raspberry Pi，因为 Wi-Fi 很复杂。啊，好的，对。但你可以随时从 Arduino 开始，与……如果你要与
to sensors and stuff like if you want to read a temperature and send you an email when the temperature gets over 75 degrees yeah exactly like you could start on an arduino for instance and like learn how to talk to the sensors read it and you can hook it up to your computer right so you can like plug in the usb cord to your computer and it'll show up as a serial port then you can just write a simple program to read the temperature off the serial port send the email and then once that's working like you have all the pieces that if you wanted to do it, like on a Raspberry Pi, you would just strip out one little part in the middle and kind of put the other two pieces on the Raspberry Pi and do the same thing. Got it. But yeah, people forget you on your Arduino. It plugs into your computer.
传感器之类的东西通信，比如如果你想读取温度并在温度超过 75 度时给你发电子邮件，是的，完全正确。比如你可以从 Arduino 开始，学习如何与传感器通信，读取它，然后你可以把它连接到你的电脑上。所以你可以把 USB 线插到你的电脑上，它会显示为一个串口，然后你就可以写一个简单的程序从串口读取温度，发送电子邮件，一旦那工作了，你就有所有的部分，如果你想在 Raspberry Pi 上做，你只需要去掉中间的一小部分，把另外两个部分放在 Raspberry Pi 上做同样的事情。明白了。但人们忘记了你在 Arduino 上。它插在你的电脑上。
It can. it can yeah me I wanted to Write something that you does world domination, but I figure like getting the temperature of your house is pretty much the same thing, okay? And then and then stream it over cereal Yes, so then yeah, I mean it would be fine All right cool time for our debugging discussion. Debugging. Debugging. Debugging.
它可以，它可以。我本来想写一些能统治世界的东西，但我想获取你房子的温度几乎是一回事，好的？然后通过串口流式传输。是的，所以，是的，我的意思是那会很好。好的，酷，是时候进行我们的调试讨论了。调试。调试。调试。
Debug, like defense. Debugging. Debugging. Well, first, Jason, tell us about the kinds of things you would need to debug. Yeah, so what are the kind of problems you have as a coder? So the most obvious is a crasher, right? So you have, I'm writing my temperature sensor that also takes over the world, and I divide
调试，就像防御。调试。调试。好吧，首先，杰森，告诉我们你需要调试的各种事情。是的，作为一名程序员，你有什么样的问题？最明显的是崩溃，对吧？所以你有，我正在写我的温度传感器，它也接管了世界，我除以
by the current temperature. And all of a sudden, strangely enough, when it's 0 degrees Celsius, my program crashes, because there's a divide by 0. that's why you shouldn't use celsius tons of hate mail now yeah i mean that's also why you shouldn't use metric stop stop stop no no this is not our real belief yeah these are not our real opinions okay so uh second is hang or slowness right so a hang is where you know it just all of a sudden they also call it a freeze you know it's where it's just you've entered some bad state and just nothing yeah it's gonna be like an infinite loop for
当前温度。突然间，奇怪的是，当它是 0 摄氏度时，我的程序崩溃了，因为有除以 0。这就是为什么你不应该使用摄氏度，现在有大量的仇恨邮件。是的，我的意思是，这也是为什么你不应该使用公制。停，停，停，不，不，这不是我们真正的信仰。是的，这些不是我们真正的观点。好的，所以第二个是挂起或缓慢，对吧？所以挂起是，你知道，它突然间……他们也称之为冻结，你知道，这是你进入了某种糟糕的状态，什么都没有。是的，它就像一个无限循环，比如
instance like it's just stuck yeah exactly or infinite recursion yeah it's continuing continuing just so incredibly slowly that it feels like it's frozen. Wrong answer where you expected the answer, the meaning of life, and you got 43 and a half. And it's like, whoops. Memory or thread leak. So if your program, over time, the memory usage goes up, up, up, up up up up but eventually your computer runs out of memory and dies or if you know every few seconds you're creating a thread and you're not deleting any threads you know after like 30 40 000 of that you'll your computer will run out of threads and blow up um these are all uh these are all real things that can happen
它只是卡住了。是的，完全正确。或者无限递归。是的，它在继续，继续，如此缓慢，以至于感觉它冻结了。错误的答案，当你期望得到答案，生命的意义，而你得到了 43.5。就像，哎呀。内存或线程泄漏。所以如果你的程序，随着时间的推移，内存使用量上升，上升，上升，但最终你的电脑内存耗尽并死机，或者如果你每隔几秒钟创建一个线程，而你没有删除任何线程，你知道，在 30 到 40,000 次之后，你的电脑内存会耗尽并爆炸。嗯，这些都是真实会发生的事情。
and uh so that's i figure that covers the majority of the bugs. Yeah, there's other ones. You could get the common ones on a computer with an operating system, like a page fault. Like if you have an errant pointer, you try to null dereference. So most of these, I guess, would apply. That would apply to a C or C++. If you had null and you tried to dereference it,
所以我想这涵盖了大部分错误。是的，还有其他的。你可以在带有操作系统的计算机上遇到常见的错误，比如页面错误。比如如果你有一个错误的指针，你尝试空解引用。所以我想大多数这些都会适用。那适用于 C 或 C++。如果你有 null 并且你尝试解引用它，
typically that will get caught by the operating system and you'll you'll get some sort of crash so i guess that's a crasher but um caused by a different oh yeah yeah yeah actually no you you're right we should have like a buffer overrun oh buffer overruns are another one yeah yeah so buffer overrun is very simply you know you uh uh you have an array of size four, and you try and get the 27th element of that array. You're actually, you know, in C or a low-level language, you will get something, but it definitely won't be what you want.
通常那会被操作系统捕获，你会得到某种崩溃，所以我猜那是一个崩溃，但……由不同的……哦，是的，是的，实际上不，你是对的，我们应该有缓冲区溢出。哦，缓冲区溢出是另一个，是的，是的。所以缓冲区溢出非常简单，你知道，你有一个大小为 4 的数组，你尝试获取该数组的第 27 个元素。你实际上，你知道，在 C 或低级语言中，你会得到一些东西，但它绝对不会是你想要的。
Or you might get a crash, depending. Oh, I guess that's, yeah, that's true. Like, if you have the protected access or protected memory space or, yeah. So in the good case, it crashes. Like if you have the protected access or protected memory space. Yeah. So in the good case, it crashes. In the bad case, you just get a number that is probably close to, it could very well be a sensible number, but not what you want. Yeah.
或者你可能会得到一个崩溃，取决于情况。哦，我猜那是，是的，那是真的。比如，如果你有受保护的访问或受保护的内存空间。是的。所以在好的情况下，它会崩溃。比如如果你有受保护的访问或受保护的内存空间。是的。所以在好的情况下，它会崩溃。在坏的情况下，你只是得到一个数字，它很可能接近，它很可能是一个合理的数字，但不是你想要的。是的。
Makes sense. So then the techniques for debugging. So I was telling Jason before the show, I actually consider myself to be pretty good at debugging, mostly because I tend to be able to track down where the problem is and isolate it very quickly, if not fix it. Not all the time, right? I'm not saying I'm the world's best, but I just find this I call divide and conquer, which is basically about finding out where the problem is not. So if you know there's a problem in the code, the more of the code you can say it's not a problem, then the faster you can find what is the problem. So a lot of people I find try to consider everything in the system that influences a given answer. So you get 43 and a half. Well, what are all the inputs that influences a given answer right so you get 43
有道理。那么调试的技术。所以我在节目开始前告诉杰森，我实际上认为自己很擅长调试，主要是因为我倾向于能够追踪问题所在并非常迅速地隔离它，如果不能修复它的话。不是每次都这样，对吧？我不是说我是世界上最好的，但我只是发现我称之为“分而治之”，这基本上是关于找出问题不在哪里。所以如果你知道代码中有问题，你能排除的代码越多，你就能越快地找到问题所在。所以我发现很多人试图考虑系统中影响给定答案的一切。所以你得到了 43.5。好吧，所有影响给定答案的输入是什么？对，所以你得到了 43
and a half well what are all the inputs that lead to give me 43 and a half um and that can you know if you just sit there and think about it conceptually it can take a long time versus dividing and conquering would be like going and saying okay here's a bunch of computation and then i add to it this other bunch of computation and i know what the results of you know the left half should be and what the results of, you know, the left half should be and what the results of the right half should be. And you look for which half has the wrong answer. And then you keep tracing back and you keep dividing, right?
一半，好吧，那么导致我得到43.5的所有输入是什么呢？嗯，如果你只是坐在那里从概念上思考，这可能需要很长时间，而分而治之的方法就像是说，好吧，这里有一堆计算，然后我再加上另一堆计算，我知道左半部分的结果应该是什么，也知道右半部分的结果应该是什么。然后你寻找哪一半的结果是错误的。接着你不断回溯，不断进行拆分，对吧？
And you're eliminating whole portions of the system. Yeah, I do exactly the same thing. I just kind of thought everyone did that. No, no. Really? Yeah. Oh, all right. Like a lot of people I'm saying is like,
你正在消除系统的整个部分。是的，我做的完全一样。我只是以为每个人都这样做。不，不。真的吗？是的。哦，好吧。我是说很多人，就像是，
they try to look like audit the code or like think conceptually for like long periods of time and say where could be the problem. Versus me, I'm much more likely to just start going in and start like using techniques we're about to talk about, like just start hacking up the code and like look for what gets the right or wrong answer and where does it go wrong.
他们试图审计代码，或者长时间进行概念性思考，然后说问题可能出在哪里。而我，我更有可能直接开始动手，使用我们即将讨论的技术，比如直接开始修改代码，寻找是什么导致了正确或错误的结果，以及它是在哪里出错的。
Yeah, I'm exactly the same way. But that is not common. Wow. Or at least it may be, I haven't, i don't observe that to be the case and i'm not saying that way it's always faster because if you sit there and think about it meditatively it's log n time yeah but if you think about it meditatively you could get it like right away right a login login algorithm isn't always the an n squared algorithm could be faster if N is super, super, super small. Yeah, or I guess it's order one if you just look at the file
是的，我完全一样。但这并不常见。哇。或者至少可能是这样，我没有观察到这种情况，我并不是说这种方法总是更快，因为如果你坐在那里冥想式地思考，那是对数时间复杂度，是的，但如果你冥想式地思考，你可能立刻就能得到答案，对吧？一个对数时间算法并不总是……一个平方时间算法如果N非常、非常、非常小，可能会更快。是的，或者我想如果你只是看文件，那就是常数时间复杂度，
and know the answer. Well, it's the whole coefficient thing, right? So mine might be order N-squared, but with a big coefficient... Or order a login algorithm, but with a big coefficient. And then you may have an N-squared algorithm with a tiny coefficient.
并且知道答案。嗯，这就是整个系数的问题，对吧？所以我的可能是平方时间复杂度，但有一个很大的系数……或者是一个对数时间算法，但有一个很大的系数。然后你可能有一个平方时间算法，但系数很小。
Yeah, yeah. Anyways, blah, blah, blah, that was nerdy. And so yeah, so I mean, that works for some people, but for me, I find it very useful, even conceptually, just to think about like what systems are in or out of play in trying to find the problem. Yeah, that makes sense. So another technique is logging.
是的，是的。总之，巴拉巴拉，那太书呆子气了。所以是的，我的意思是，这对某些人有效，但对我来说，我发现即使在概念上，思考哪些系统在起作用或不起作用来寻找问题也非常有用。是的，这很有道理。所以另一种技术是日志记录。
Obviously, the simplest is print statements. So if the function takes in two ints and is supposed to return their sum, and it's returning something completely bogus, then you want to put a print statement in that function where you print the two ints and what you think the sum is before you return. And then from that, you can kind of figure out, oops, you know, my Arduino is too hot
显然，最简单的是打印语句。所以如果函数接收两个整数并应该返回它们的和，但它返回了一些完全荒谬的东西，那么你想要在那个函数中放一个打印语句，在返回之前打印这两个整数和你认为的和。然后从那里，你可以弄清楚，哎呀，你知道，我的Arduino太热了，
and my sum function is not working. So or you can find out that you're like that guy on the blog and you used a minus instead of a plus sign. Another thing you can have is rolling files. So I mean, obviously, if you keep putting print state, you have to do one of two things, you either have to put them in the print statement, and then fix the problem and then take the print statement out. But then if you do that, as your program gets bigger and bigger and bigger, you'll eventually discover a problem that happened six months ago.
而且我的求和函数无法工作。所以，或者你可以发现你就像博客上的那个家伙，你用减号代替了加号。你可以拥有的另一件事是滚动日志文件。所以我的意思是，显然，如果你一直放打印语句，你必须做两件事之一，你要么必须把它们放在打印语句中，然后修复问题，然后把打印语句拿出来。但如果你这样做，随着你的程序变得越来越大，你最终会发现一个六个月前发生的问题。
And now you have no more print statements anywhere in your code, and you have to go back and put them all in. So a lot of people just leave the prints in, but now your program becomes really slow, because printing to the screen halts the processor and things like that. So you can log to a file and then you can say, okay, I'm going to take all these print statements and dump it into a file where it can be printed really quickly because it doesn't have to go straight to my eye. And then every day I'll
现在你的代码中没有任何打印语句了，你必须回去把它们全部放进去。所以很多人只是把打印语句留在里面，但现在你的程序变得非常慢，因为打印到屏幕会暂停处理器之类的。所以你可以记录到一个文件中，然后你可以说，好吧，我要把所有这些打印语句转储到一个文件中，在那里它可以被非常快地打印出来，因为它不必直接进入我的眼睛。然后每天我会
delete the file and start over. So that's pretty common is to have a lot of debug logging and to dump it to a file or even have a level of logging that gets thrown away. And you only use that level of logging when you know something's wrong. Right. Or like the function actually no ops in the case where your system logging level is set higher than the log message you're trying to output. Right. So I see a lot. And depending on the language you're using, there's different ways of doing that. But logging can still be problematic
删除文件并重新开始。所以有很多调试日志并将其转储到文件，甚至拥有一个会被丢弃的日志级别是非常常见的。你只有在知道有问题时才使用该级别的日志。对。或者像函数实际上在你的系统日志级别设置得高于你试图输出的日志消息时执行空操作。对。所以我看到了很多。根据你使用的语言，有不同的方法来做到这一点。但日志记录仍然可能是有问题的，
because they're, like as Jason pointed out, but even just printing to a file still can, depending on your application, be hugely expensive relative to what you're trying to do. So if you're trying to process a million, you know, items of data and you're printing 10 things for each one, this isn't going to work.
因为，正如Jason指出的那样，即使只是打印到文件，根据你的应用程序，相对于你试图做的事情，仍然可能是非常昂贵的。所以如果你试图处理一百万个数据项，并且你为每一个打印10个东西，这是行不通的。
Also, it's going to be very hard to track through if only a couple of them are having problems, track through all that massive amount of data you've generated looking for problems. Yeah, so sometimes you need to take a certain function and just really dive in and you're willing to just take an extreme amount of time to find some bug that's very nuanced and that's where things like debuggers can really help um so for c and c plus plus there's gdb or if you're using llvm if you're using the clang compiler there's lldb um. For JavaScript, there's Firebug, which is pretty cool. Chrome has a debugger, too. It might just be called the Chrome debugger. For Python, there's PDB.
此外，如果只有其中几个有问题，要跟踪所有你生成的海量数据来寻找问题将非常困难。是的，所以有时你需要拿出一个特定的函数并真正深入研究，你愿意花大量的时间来寻找一些非常细微的错误，这就是调试器真正可以提供帮助的地方。嗯，对于C和C++，有GDB，或者如果你使用LLVM，如果你使用Clang编译器，有LLDB。对于JavaScript，有Firebug，这很酷。Chrome也有一个调试器。它可能就叫Chrome调试器。对于Python，有PDB。
And for Java, there's JDB or JDWP, which is not something you would use directly, but you would use through an IDE. So if you ever are coding Java in Eclipse, and you're writing some web server, and some function is just really hokey, and you could try to test that function in isolation, you could run some simple Eclipse program in debug mode. And that's actually using this JDWP to start your program up in debug mode,
对于Java，有JDB或JDWP，这不是你会直接使用的东西，但你会通过IDE使用它。所以如果你在Eclipse中编写Java代码，并且你正在编写一些Web服务器，而某个函数真的很烂，你可以尝试孤立地测试该函数，你可以在调试模式下运行一些简单的Eclipse程序。这实际上就是使用这个JDWP以调试模式启动你的程序，
and then to talk to it through this protocol. So Java has sort of API for debugging, which is pretty cool. And so that's how these IDs work. Another thing is that, you know, it may not be obvious that something wrong is happening, but just that your program runs slower than you expect it to. You didn't implement the dynamic programming solution, and instead you implemented the N-squared solution. But you still think you can get there with N-squared, but you need to understand functions are taking too long. And then you need to do what's called profiling.
然后通过这个协议与它对话。所以Java有某种用于调试的API，这很酷。这就是这些IDE的工作方式。另一件事是，你知道，发生错误可能并不明显，只是你的程序运行速度比你预期的要慢。你没有实现动态规划解决方案，而是实现了平方时间解决方案。但你仍然认为你可以用平方时间达到目标，但你需要了解函数花费了太长时间。然后你需要做所谓的性能分析。
That's right. That's right. So actually, interestingly enough, Morton Nielsen posted on the Google Plus page and asked us to do a show on profiling. And so this show on debugging was a good opportunity to talk about this. So yeah, if we could talk about profiling in a nutshell. Yeah, basically profiling is where you run your program, hopefully in as normal an environment as possible. Obviously, you know, the act of adding profiling taints the program, but you try to keep that as low as possible. And a lot of these tools are optimized for that and then you finish your program hopefully doing some task that's that's nominal for that program and at the end you get this cool dump this this graph which shows what functions you spent the most time in and you know
没错。没错。所以实际上，有趣的是，Morton Nielsen在Google Plus页面上发帖，要求我们做一个关于性能分析的节目。所以这个关于调试的节目是一个谈论这个的好机会。所以是的，如果我们能简要谈谈性能分析。是的，基本上性能分析就是你运行你的程序，希望在尽可能正常的环境中。显然，你知道，添加性能分析的行为会污染程序，但你尽量保持这种影响尽可能小。而且许多这些工具都为此进行了优化，然后你完成你的程序，希望执行一些对该程序来说是标称的任务，最后你得到这个很酷的转储，这个图表，它显示了你花费时间最多的函数，你知道，
what lines of code were the hot spots and things like that and so there are a couple different ways of of doing that so um there we'll talk about some tools in. And so there are a couple of different ways of doing that. So we'll talk about some tools in a second, but there's all kind of two ways I know of doing it. One is where you essentially for every function call, you add a little bit of, you generate a little bit of metadata. So in the prelude and postlude to a function.
哪些代码行是热点等等，所以有几种不同的方法来做到这一点。所以嗯，我们稍后会谈论一些工具。所以有几种不同的方法来做到这一点。所以我们稍后会谈论一些工具，但我知道有两种方法。一种是你本质上为每个函数调用添加一点点，你生成一点点元数据。所以在函数的前奏和后奏中。
So this is like in your programming language, when you go from one function to another the compiler inserts a little bit of code in between them or you do a little bit of code in between those two calls to say that you're calling a new function and what the current time is and then you're returning from this function and what the you know current time is and if you do that for all the functions you'll get not the correct time, but relatively the correct times for how long each function takes. And then for functions which are called over and over and over again, of course, they'll
所以这就像在你的编程语言中，当你从一个函数转到另一个函数时，编译器在它们之间插入一点点代码，或者你在那两个调用之间做一点点代码，来说明你正在调用一个新函数以及当前时间是多少，然后你从这个函数返回以及当前时间是多少，如果你对所有函数都这样做，你将得到的不是正确的时间，而是关于每个函数花费多长时间的相对正确的时间。然后对于那些被反复调用的函数，当然，它们会
have lots of entries. And if you sum up all their time, even though each individual time may be very tiny, if you sum up all the times, it could be a huge portion of your program. So think like a very tight inner loop calls some function for graphics processing could end up taking a long time in aggregate. And you'll be able to catch that by essentially looking at all these every time the function call started and every time it ended. Now, the problem, as Jason pointed out, depending on what other systems you interact with, like
有很多条目。如果你把它们的所有时间加起来，即使每个单独的时间可能非常微小，如果你把所有时间加起来，它可能是你程序的一大部分。所以想想一个非常紧凑的内部循环调用某个用于图形处理的函数，最终可能会在总量上花费很长时间。你将能够通过本质上查看所有这些函数调用开始和结束的时间来捕捉到这一点。现在，正如Jason指出的那样，问题在于，取决于你与之交互的其他系统，比如
let's say you're also talking to an sql database while doing this you know code there could be timeouts associated with the database and so if your code runs really really slow because of all this extra data is generating then your sql you know query times out your connection times out and you have to start it over and it just changes fundamentally the way your program interacts with other processes um and so it's not always desirable to do that although if you can do it that kind of way is the best because it gives you the complete answer um but the other alternative which statistically in the long run ends up being the same as random sample profiling, which means that at a random time, you wake up via an interrupt or whatever, you stop your program, and you ask it what current line of code it's running at. So in embedded, we often have to do this in a custom way,
假设你在做这段代码的同时也在与SQL数据库对话，你知道，数据库可能会有超时，所以如果你的代码因为所有这些额外生成的数据而运行得非常非常慢，那么你的SQL查询就会超时，你的连接就会超时，你必须重新开始，它从根本上改变了你的程序与其他进程交互的方式。所以这样做并不总是可取的，尽管如果你能以那种方式做到，那是最好的，因为它给了你完整的答案。但另一种选择，从统计学上讲，长期来看最终是一样的，是随机采样性能分析，这意味着在随机时间，你通过中断或其他方式唤醒，你停止你的程序，并询问它当前正在运行哪一行代码。所以在嵌入式中，我们经常必须以自定义方式执行此操作，
where you have an interrupt that fires, and you look at what the program counter that was pushed onto the stack was, which is where you'll return when your interrupt finishes and you you know essentially put that return location somewhere and then at the you know end of some interval you go look at all those return locations and then statistically in aggregate you know what functions you're spending time in by randomly when you woke up and asked the processor what it was doing where was it at then you build up a picture of where you're spending time but you could miss certain functions like if a function is only called once in a while and for a very brief period of time you may not catch it randomly but then you may you wouldn't care about it because it doesn't take
你有一个触发的中断，你查看被推入堆栈的程序计数器是什么，这就是你的中断完成时你将返回的地方，然后你本质上把那个返回位置放在某个地方，然后在某个间隔结束时，你去查看所有那些返回位置，然后从统计学上讲，你通过随机唤醒并询问处理器它在做什么，它当时在哪里，从而知道你花费时间在哪些函数中，然后你建立了一个关于你花费时间在哪里的图景，但你可能会错过某些函数，比如如果一个函数只是偶尔被调用，并且持续时间非常短，你可能不会随机捕捉到它，但那样的话你也不会关心它，因为它不需要
very long to run yeah that makes sense yeah it's like, you know, we talked about the acceptance-rejection sampling like a few shows ago and how you could like estimate the volume of a surface and all that stuff. This is basically that. I mean, this is just pure acceptance sampling.
很长时间来运行。是的，这很有道理。是的，就像，你知道，我们几期节目之前谈到了接受-拒绝采样，以及你如何估计表面的体积等等。这基本上就是那样。我的意思是，这纯粹是接受采样。
But yeah, I mean, to Patrick's point, right, if you take enough samples, then yeah, it's like a Monte Carlo approximation of the actual time. And it's much easier to implement. Yeah, but it does have a flaw where with random sample profiling that if, for instance, like you do a lot of math operations, like you take a lot of sines or cosines and you are spending a lot of time in that code but it's called from many many different parts of the system it will only tell you that you spent a lot of time computing cosines but not for what purpose like what was the one level above function you typically don't get why can't you unwind the whole it depends so yes it adds the only if it unwinds the stack as well
但是是的，我的意思是，回到Patrick的观点，对吧，如果你采集足够的样本，那么是的，这就像是实际时间的蒙特卡洛近似。而且它更容易实现。是的，但它确实有一个缺陷，即使用随机采样性能分析，如果，例如，你做了大量的数学运算，比如你做了大量的正弦或余弦运算，并且你花费了大量时间在那段代码中，但它被系统中的许多不同部分调用，它只会告诉你你花费了大量时间计算余弦，但不知道是为了什么目的，比如上一级函数是什么。你通常得不到，为什么不能展开整个……这取决于，所以是的，它添加了，只有在它也展开堆栈时。
so only if it records their current call stack as well so only if it records okay their current call stack yeah right which will get to a horror story why like a lot of times in low level embedded you can't actually get the whole call stack oh okay cool um so yeah so the uh oh man i was totally gonna say something i forgot. I'm sure it was important. Oh, yeah, yeah, I remember. Okay, so Boost has this pretty cool thing called Scoped Timer, which is meant for the thing Patrick talked about earlier where you want to time every function.
所以只有在它也记录它们当前的调用堆栈时。所以只有在它记录，好的，它们当前的调用堆栈。是的，对，这将引出一个恐怖故事，为什么很多时候在低级嵌入式中，你实际上无法获得整个调用堆栈。哦，好的，酷。嗯，所以是的，那个……哦，天哪，我本来要说什么，我忘了。我相信这很重要。哦，是的，是的，我想起来了。好的，所以Boost有一个非常酷的东西叫Scoped Timer，它是为了Patrick之前谈到的那种情况，你想对每个函数进行计时。
And I thought it was kind of clever. It's a timer object, and in the constructor of the object, it gets the time, and in the destructor of the object, it gets the time and takes a difference and prints it and so the idea is like you know as long as you create the scoped timer on the stack um you know you don't use new scope timer no one would ever do that so as long as you create on the stack then you don't have to create the end version like it just naturally happens when you return from the function. And you could even have, like, within a function,
我觉得它有点聪明。它是一个计时器对象，在对象的构造函数中，它获取时间，在对象的析构函数中，它获取时间并取差值并打印出来。所以这个想法是，你知道，只要你在堆栈上创建Scoped Timer，嗯，你知道，你不会使用new scope timer，没有人会那样做。所以只要你在堆栈上创建，那么你就不必创建结束版本，它只是在你从函数返回时自然发生。你甚至可以，比如，在一个函数内，
you could put little curly braces and put a scope timer such that, you know, you know it's going to go out of scope. I still find the, like, non, like, the curly braces without, and C or C++ you're talking about, but, like, the curly braces for creating local scope without something at the opening curly brace, still find that disturbing really like i've seen it so many times that i still find it jarring like as such a weird notation as long as you're creating the variable right afterwards i'm okay with it but if you just have one kind of floating then yeah i
你可以放一些小花括号并放一个作用域计时器，这样，你知道，你知道它会超出作用域。我仍然觉得，比如，非，比如，花括号没有，在C或C++中你谈论的是，但是，比如，用于创建局部作用域的花括号，在开花括号处没有东西，仍然觉得那很令人不安。真的，就像我见过它很多次了，但我仍然觉得它很刺耳，这是一种很奇怪的符号。只要你在之后立即创建变量，我就没问题，但如果你只是有一个悬浮的，那么是的，我
kind of think why did this why is this here there are lots of reasons for doing it. It's just always, like, it never jived with me. It always just... Okay. So some random tools for this. So C or C++, you're probably going to be using Gprof. For JavaScript, the Firefox and Chrome both have a pretty good profiler built in. One interesting thing is they'll give very different results
有点想为什么这个，为什么这个在这里。有很多理由这样做。它总是，就像，它从来没有和我产生共鸣。它总是只是……好的。所以一些随机的工具。所以C或C++，你可能要使用Gprof。对于JavaScript，Firefox和Chrome都内置了一个相当不错的性能分析器。一件有趣的事情是它们会给出非常不同的结果，
um i guess it's not that interesting because you know they're completely different browsers right but um um but like there are some things that firefox i think adds like counts in the profile that chrome doesn't and things like that um python has profile or c profile i thought this kind of interesting like python has a lot of these libraries where they have like a C version, like they have pickle and C pickle, they have profile and C profile, and I always kind of thought, why would you ever use profile when the C profile is just better in every way, the only thing I can imagine is you might not exist on every architecture or something like that.
嗯，我想这并不那么有趣，因为你知道它们是完全不同的浏览器，对吧。但是嗯，但是比如有一些Firefox我认为添加的东西，比如性能分析中的计数，而Chrome没有，诸如此类。Python有profile或cProfile。我觉得这很有趣，比如Python有很多这样的库，它们有C版本，比如它们有pickle和Cpickle，它们有profile和cProfile，我一直有点想，为什么你会使用profile，而cProfile在各方面都更好？我唯一能想到的是你可能在每个架构上都不存在，或者类似的东西。
Um, so I put both in just in case, but you're almost certainly going to want to use C profile if you're doing Python. The, so, sorry for memory leaks. A tool I've used before is Valgrind, which is extremely interesting because you don't actually run your program
嗯，所以我把两者都放进去了，以防万一，但如果你在做Python，你几乎肯定会想要使用cProfile。那么，抱歉，关于内存泄漏。我以前用过的一个工具是Valgrind，它非常有趣，因为你实际上并没有运行你的程序
on the processor when you run it through Valgrind, but Valgrind instead looks at your code and basically hijacks it so when it sees you using memory, it tags it so that it knows when you free it and when you don't. And this has, again, a problem we talked about before where it does change the timing of your code,
在处理器上，当你通过Valgrind运行它时，但Valgrind反而查看你的代码并基本上劫持它，所以当它看到你使用内存时，它会标记它，以便它知道你何时释放它以及何时不释放它。这再次有一个我们之前谈到的问题，即它确实改变了你代码的时间，
but for memory allocation, deallocation is very useful because because it tags all every time you allocate memory it says when you created it when you freed it um and i don't remember i think it even maybe gives you line numbers where you um did it i can't remember now it's been too long since i used it yeah it does it gives you it gives you line numbers yeah so it a really, really powerful tool for Linux-based systems. I don't know if there's something equivalent in Windows and when you're not using an operating system, there's no dice. Yeah, so for Mac, there's also,
但对于内存分配，释放是非常有用的，因为因为它标记了所有，每次你分配内存时，它都会说你何时创建它，何时释放它。嗯，我不记得了，我想它甚至可能给你行号，你在哪里做了它，我不记得了，我使用它已经太久了。是的，它确实，它给你行号，是的。所以它是一个非常、非常强大的工具，用于基于Linux的系统。我不知道Windows中是否有等效的东西，当你没有使用操作系统时，没戏。是的，所以对于Mac，也有，
you can build Valgrind for Mac. For Windows, I believe you can build Valgrind, but the catch is your binary must have also been built with GCC or Clang. So if you build your binary using Visual Studio, then there's no hope. No hope with Valgrind, but there are other, like Intel has a tool you can pay for. If you're already paying for Visual Studio, they probably figure paying is something you're used to. You like paying. Yeah, you like paying. Yeah, another one is address sanitizer. It's very similar to Valgrind. It's not as heavy.
你可以为Mac构建Valgrind。对于Windows，我相信你可以构建Valgrind，但问题是你的二进制文件也必须是用GCC或Clang构建的。所以如果你使用Visual Studio构建你的二进制文件，那么就没有希望了。Valgrind没有希望，但还有其他的，比如Intel有一个你可以付费购买的工具。如果你已经在为Visual Studio付费，他们可能认为付费是你习惯的事情。你喜欢付费。是的，你喜欢付费。是的，另一个是地址消毒器（Address Sanitizer）。它与Valgrind非常相似。它没有那么重。
In fact, many people run address sanitizer all the time because it's only like, I think, a 30% or 40% hit. And most people say, oh, I'd rather buy 40% more computers than have an address out-of-bounds error. And so many companies run with address sanitized run all the time. It's much more lightweight than Valgrind, but it only catches a subset of the errors. For automated testing, you know, you can write,
事实上，许多人一直运行地址消毒器，因为它只有，我想，30%或40%的性能损失。大多数人说，哦，我宁愿多买40%的计算机，也不愿有地址越界错误。所以许多公司一直运行地址消毒。它比Valgrind轻量得多，但它只捕捉错误的子集。对于自动化测试，你知道，你可以编写，
we had a show about unit tests. That's great. Integration tests. There's also a great kind of testing called fuzz testing, which is essentially throwing randomly generated data at your program. So this is really good, for instance, if you think about a program which accepts packets over the internet, for instance, and you say, I'm checking for malformed TCP packets. Well, that's great, except you have some sort of internal finite state machine that's
我们有一个关于单元测试的节目。那太棒了。集成测试。还有一种很棒的测试叫模糊测试（fuzz testing），它本质上是向你的程序抛出随机生成的数据。所以这真的很好，例如，如果你考虑一个通过互联网接收数据包的程序，例如，你说，我正在检查格式错误的TCP数据包。好吧，那很好，除了你有一些内部有限状态机，它
looking for certain bit patterns. And if I keep throwing enough random stuff at you, eventually I'll get something that looks an awful lot like a real packet, but is flawed in some way that if you were crafting inputs, you would never think about. And you can cause all sorts of crazy crashes and end up getting found. Every story
正在寻找特定的位模式。如果我一直向你抛出足够的随机东西，最终我会得到一些看起来非常像真实数据包的东西，但在某种程度上是有缺陷的，如果你在精心制作输入，你永远不会想到。你可以导致各种疯狂的崩溃，并最终被发现。每一个故事
I've ever heard about, and maybe it's confirmation bias, but every story I've ever read about someone who decided to try doing fuzz testing has always found whole classes of errors they weren't catching in other ways. Yeah, definitely. I mean, I've used the gremlins.js, which is a visual version of fuzz testing.
我听说过的，也许是确认偏见，但我读过的每一个关于有人决定尝试进行模糊测试的故事，总是发现他们没有通过其他方式捕捉到的整类错误。是的，绝对。我的意思是，我使用过gremlins.js，它是模糊测试的可视化版本。
Basically, you load gremlins.js into your browser while you're looking at a website and you can even do this on websites that aren't yours which is kind of cool like you can do this on new york times or whatever but you can uh you can load gremlins.js and then you can say i think it's like gremlins.spawn and it will just randomly and very quickly start clicking all over the screen and typing into all the input boxes and hitting enter and clicking all over the screen and typing into all the input boxes and hitting enter and clicking on all the buttons. Did you just recommend people to try hacking the New York Times, Jason?
基本上，当你查看网站时，你将gremlins.js加载到你的浏览器中，你甚至可以在不是你的网站上这样做，这很酷，比如你可以在纽约时报或任何地方这样做，但你可以，你可以加载gremlins.js，然后你可以说，我想是gremlins.spawn，它会随机且非常快地开始点击屏幕各处，并在所有输入框中输入内容，然后按回车，点击屏幕各处，并在所有输入框中输入内容，然后按回车，点击所有按钮。Jason，你刚才是在建议人们尝试黑掉纽约时报吗？
I think I just DDoSed the New York Times, like thousands of people. So you could do this on your own website. And the short story here is, I have this internal website that I use Docker for, which we can go back to that. But I ran this Gremlins on it, and it completely blew up. Like, even the server died.
我想我刚刚对纽约时报进行了DDoS攻击，就像成千上万的人一样。所以你可以在你自己的网站上这样做。这里简短的故事是，我有一个内部网站，我使用Docker，我们可以回到那个话题。但我对它运行了这个Gremlins，它完全炸了。就像，连服务器都死了。
Everything died. And, you know, I went through several iterations. I basically got to the point where i just like it was too hard like i just the gremlins beat me and uh i still have to do a lot more work to to overcome it so if you know where jason lives you can uh run gremlins on his website and crash all his computers yeah that's right but you will be absolutely amazed especially with javascript where or you know with web design where you might have a lot going on on a website but you don't really expect all of it to be engaged at the same time um you will be amazed at how broken
一切都死了。而且，你知道，我经历了几个迭代。我基本上到了那种地步，我只是，太难了，就像我，Gremlins打败了我，而且我仍然需要做更多的工作来克服它。所以如果你知道Jason住在哪里，你可以，在你的网站上运行Gremlins并让他的所有计算机崩溃。是的，没错。但你会感到非常惊讶，特别是在JavaScript中，或者你知道，在网页设计中，你可能在网站上有很多事情发生，但你并不真正期望它们同时被参与，嗯，你会惊讶于它是多么破碎。
um you know like gremlins will actually click buttons that aren't visible because i mean technically someone can just make them visible in the browser and click them. Like, it's possible, you know? And so if you're not handling that on the server side, your thing just explodes. So, yeah, check that out. You guys, your web programming and invisible buttons. I don't even know what's going on.
嗯，你知道，比如Gremlins实际上会点击不可见的按钮，因为我的意思是，从技术上讲，有人可以在浏览器中让它们可见并点击它们。就像，这是可能的，你知道吗？所以如果你没有在服务器端处理这个问题，你的东西就会爆炸。所以，是的，去看看那个。你们，你们的网页编程和不可见的按钮。我甚至不知道发生了什么。
All right. Also, tools for iOS and Android to do similar things. Randomly click your app looking for problems. We didn't even talk about fuzz testing for, like, sanitation of inputs for, like, SQL injection and stuff like that, which is also very important. Oh, yeah. Because it turns out there's, like, all sorts of Unicode characters that also do equivalent things and escaping and escaping escaping and oh yep all sorts of weirdness that you can do uh and then of course all of it's very important for when you're running services in production or uh on you know user devices that you have reporting crash reporting
好的。此外，iOS和Android也有类似的工具。随机点击你的应用程序寻找问题。我们甚至没有谈论用于，比如，SQL注入等输入的消毒的模糊测试，这也是非常重要的。哦，是的。因为事实证明，有各种各样的Unicode字符也会做等效的事情，还有转义和转义转义，哦，是的，你可以做各种奇怪的事情。然后当然，所有这些对于你在生产环境中运行服务，或者在用户设备上运行服务时，拥有报告、崩溃报告非常重要。
aggregate reporting reporting some dashboard where you can go to and say did my newest release cause more crashes than normal or what crashes are there why are why is it crashing unexpected that's a good point like when you release things to you know millions or maybe billions of people it's going to crash for a lot of them you know i mean so it's not like you know you're going to release something and and uh after doing all the debugging we just talked about it's just 100 right the reality is if you're really selling to a billion people you're going to get thousands of crash reports yeah i i don't think i mean i can't say for certain but i mean there's all sorts of reasons that aren't even your fault that it could crash for right like misconfigured whatever like you're you're expecting
聚合报告，报告到某个你可以去的仪表板，并说我的最新版本是否导致了比平时更多的崩溃，或者有什么崩溃，为什么，为什么它会意外崩溃。这是一个很好的观点，就像当你向，你知道，数百万甚至数十亿人发布东西时，它会为他们中的许多人崩溃，你知道，我的意思是，所以这不像，你知道，你会发布一些东西，并且在做了我们刚才谈到的所有调试后，它就100%正确了。现实是，如果你真的卖给十亿人，你会得到成千上万的崩溃报告。是的，我，我不认为，我的意思是，我不能肯定地说，但我的意思是，有各种各样的原因，甚至不是你的错，它可能会崩溃，对吧，比如配置错误，无论什么，比如你正在期待
some job to complete and someone pulled the power plug on their computer um like i mean or like ram you know like you store an eight and you will get an eight back 99.6 nines percent but i mean again you have a billion people so you will have that epsilon percent you will see that epsilon percent chance realized in your crash log or just like it's somebody's running on corrupted RAM or something
某个作业完成，而有人拔掉了他们计算机的电源插头，就像，我的意思是，或者像内存，你知道，你存储一个8，你会得到一个8，99.6个9的百分比，但我的意思是，再次，你有十亿人，所以你会在你的崩溃日志中看到那个epsilon百分比的机会实现，或者只是像有人在损坏的内存上运行之类的。
yeah right yeah I mean there's all sorts of reasons why crashes can happen that aren't your fault but if you kind of have looked at them and you understand and it depends a lot on the circumstances, but at least you can know that it stays at a constant level, right? Like if it goes up after you've pushed a change, like that's bad. You should understand why.
是的，对，是的。我的意思是，有各种各样的原因导致崩溃发生，而不是你的错，但如果你已经查看了它们，并且你理解了，这在很大程度上取决于情况，但至少你可以知道它保持在一个恒定的水平，对吧？就像如果它在你推送更改后上升，那是不好的。你应该明白为什么。
Yep. So. Cool. So that's sort of debugging, you know, in a nutshell. The rest we have are some interesting stories, kind of. We have for us are some interesting stories. We have some crazy stories, worse stories. Debugging is a lot about
是的。所以。酷。所以这就是调试，你知道，简而言之。剩下的我们有一些有趣的故事，算是吧。我们有，对我们来说是一些有趣的故事。我们有一些疯狂的故事，更糟糕的故事。调试很大程度上是关于
sitting around the fire pit. Yeah, sitting around the fire pit and sharing these incredible stories about either the heroic or the terrifying stories of debugging. Some terrible things have happened to me are bugs that only happen in release builds. So you can't use, as soon as you run Valgrind
坐在火坑周围。是的，坐在火坑周围，分享这些关于英雄或可怕的调试故事。发生在我身上的一些可怕的事情是只有在发布版本中才会发生的错误。所以你不能使用，一旦你运行Valgrind
or Address Sanitizer or GDB, any of these tools, the bug goes away. It's only there when you, even if you add a print statement, the bug goes away. It's like only there when you're not looking for it. Timing. That's terrible. Yes.
或Address Sanitizer或GDB，任何这些工具，错误就消失了。它只存在于你，即使你添加一个打印语句，错误也会消失。就像它只在你没有寻找它时才存在。时间。那太可怕了。是的。
They're impossible to drag down. Yeah. Not impossible. Basically, you have to just start deleting parts of your code until it stops crashing. Bugs that only happen once per day or once for some very long time. We had an issue where we were had some bug so patrick and i used to work uh at a company over on the east coast and we had a bug where to solve it um somebody finally just sat in a hot room with some machinery for eight hours straight and never got the bug and they were literally just sitting there and then after eight hours they finally got
它们是不可能被追踪到的。是的。并非不可能。基本上，你必须只是开始删除你的代码部分，直到它停止崩溃。每天只发生一次或在很长一段时间内发生一次的错误。我们有一个问题，我们有一个错误，所以Patrick和我曾经在东海岸的一家公司工作，我们有一个错误，为了解决它，嗯，有人终于只是坐在一个炎热的房间里，和一些机器在一起，连续八个小时，从来没有得到那个错误，他们实际上只是坐在那里，然后在八个小时后，他们终于得到了
the got the bug and then fortunately we were able to collect enough data that time but it had been for months it had been crashing but only you know once or twice per day and so we were never collecting the right information to fix it. Yeah, so the bugs only happen in release builds. We had a bug recently in a team I was working on where the system that we were working in, the power would essentially fluctuate depending on what you were doing. And so it would crash, but you could let... And we thought, like like someone said oh i think
得到了那个错误，然后幸运的是，我们那次能够收集到足够的数据，但它已经崩溃了几个月，但只是，你知道，每天一次或两次。所以我们从来没有收集到正确的信息来修复它。是的，所以错误只发生在发布版本中。我们最近在我工作的一个团队中有一个错误，我们工作的系统，电源基本上会根据你正在做的事情而波动。所以它会崩溃，但你可以让……我们以为，就像有人说，哦，我想
it's this they added the change and it fixed it uh and then they you know tried to send the change out for review and get it approved or whatever and i brought up to them like well hey can you prove that like taking it back out or like changing something else doesn't also fix it and they just looked at me funny went back to their desk they They, they tried it, came back. Okay. What do you know that you're not telling me? And I said, well, I was just being pessimistic. And it turned out that basically changing any line of code would fix the problem. Almost any line of code. So what it turned out is like, like I was saying, the power was fluctuating because an operation we were doing, like we were doing two back-to-back operations that took a lot of power, for instance.
是这个，他们添加了更改，它修复了它，然后他们，你知道，试图把更改发出去进行审查并获得批准，无论什么，我向他们提出，好吧，嘿，你能证明，比如把它拿出来或者改变其他东西不会也修复它吗？他们只是奇怪地看着我，回到他们的办公桌，他们，他们尝试了，回来了。好的。你知道什么你没有告诉我的？我说，好吧，我只是在悲观。结果证明，基本上改变任何一行代码都会修复这个问题。几乎任何一行代码。所以结果是，就像我说的，电源在波动，因为我们正在做的一个操作，比如我们正在做两个背靠背的操作，这些操作消耗了大量的电源，例如。
And that, you know, after the first one, the power was kind of like sagged and then you did the second one and it would fail. But if you altered the order or added anything in between them, the power could recover enough and would work fine. Oh my God.
而且那，你知道，在第一个之后，电源有点像下垂了，然后你做了第二个，它就会失败。但如果你改变了顺序或在它们之间添加了任何东西，电源就能恢复足够多，并且工作得很好。哦，我的天哪。
But that like, it turned out not to be a software problem, but actually like physically the machine we were running on was having difficulty doing what we were asking it to. And so almost any change would fix the problem. That was really hard to try. Oh, my God. Yeah, the big thing, another big problem that I had, so this is kind of bad coding on my part
但这，结果证明不是软件问题，而是实际上，我们运行的机器在做我们要求它做的事情时有困难。所以几乎任何改变都会修复这个问题。那真的很难尝试。哦，我的天哪。是的，大事，我遇到的另一个大问题，所以这对我来说有点糟糕的编码
this is like when I was very young but I built this video game and there was some crasher that happened but it was near the end of the game and being extremely naive the only way I could debug it is to play through the whole game now it wasn't that long of a game it was only like 30 minutes
这就像我非常年轻的时候，但我构建了这个视频游戏，发生了一些崩溃，但它是在游戏快结束时，而且非常天真，我能调试它的唯一方法是玩完整个游戏。现在，那不是一个很长的游戏，只有大约30分钟
but like yeah I would play 30 minutes and then i would see the crash and then i would like mess around in visual studio and and make a little bit of progress but not enough to like totally fix it and then i would repeat it was just like in hindsight it was like yeah unit test would have been great there but uh um but uh but yeah that's another one that potentially that could bite you even if you wrote unit test I could regale you with all sorts of hardware stories like address bits that were stuck so you think you're talking to one address of RAM but you're really talking it to a different one because one of the bits occasionally gets stuck
但是就像，是的，我会玩30分钟，然后我会看到崩溃，然后我会像在Visual Studio中摆弄，并取得一点点进展，但不足以完全修复它，然后我会重复。这就像，事后看来，就像，是的，单元测试在那里会很棒，但嗯，但嗯，但是的，这是另一个可能咬你的东西，即使你写了单元测试。我可以给你讲各种硬件故事，比如卡住的地址位，所以你以为你在和RAM的一个地址对话，但你实际上是在和另一个地址对话，因为其中一个位偶尔会卡住
and so when you ask for address 8 of the array you're actually getting address six, right? That wouldn't be, Oh God. Yeah. Yeah. So like the four bit, the yeah, four bit is the eight and six don't make sense, but Oh yeah. If you're asking for eight and it's giving me nine because the one bit is stuck and it's just like sometimes occasionally it gets stuck. And so when you're like indexing an array, it gets mirrored upon itself in some way. Very hard to track down. Oh man, that's intense.
所以当你要求数组的地址8时，你实际上得到的是地址6，对吧？那不会是，哦，天哪。是的。是的。所以就像四位，是的，四位是8和6没有意义，但哦，是的。如果你要求8，它给了我9，因为1位卡住了，它就像有时偶尔会卡住。所以当你像索引一个数组时，它以某种方式镜像在自身上。非常难追踪。哦，伙计，那太强烈了。
And then I was talking earlier about stack unwinding. And so one of the things that turns out when you're on like, depending on how you run your GCC or whatever, is that when you're running in, like we said, like these bare metal kind of low level programs, is that GCC can become very, very efficient at stripping out a lot of stuff. And so one of the things that it starts to do is when you push, so every time you go into a
然后我之前在谈论堆栈展开。所以当你在，比如，取决于你如何运行你的GCC或无论什么，事实证明，当你正在运行，就像我们说的，像这些裸机这种低级程序时，GCC可以变得非常、非常高效地剥离很多东西。所以它开始做的一件事是，当你推入，所以每次你进入一个
function, it pushes in C or C++. Wow, that's all our debugging stories. Java must be great, because I've written a lot of Java code and I have almost no interesting debugging stories about it. Well, there's been interesting things, but the problem is they're had by the VM. Like the guys who write the VM have all the fun. Oh, maybe.
函数，它在C或C++中推入。哇，这就是我们所有的调试故事。Java一定很棒，因为我写了很多Java代码，我几乎没有任何关于它的有趣调试故事。嗯，有一些有趣的事情，但问题是它们是由虚拟机拥有的。就像编写虚拟机的人拥有所有的乐趣。哦，也许。
So write your code in Java because apparently you end up with no interesting debugging stories. Yeah. So I had GCC, when you call into a function, pushes some bits of data onto the stack. And so in Linux, for instance, I think I'm not super familiar with it, but I
所以用Java写你的代码，因为显然你最终没有有趣的调试故事。是的。所以我有了GCC，当你调用一个函数时，将一些数据位推入堆栈。所以，在Linux中，例如，我想我不太熟悉它，但我
think it more pushes kind of like a set format, a frame, into the stack. So you have these stacked frames. And so when you crash and you get a stack dump, you can actually look through it and look for the stack. So you have these stack frames. And so when you crash and you get a stack dump, you can actually look through it and look for the frames. But it turns out not every function needs to push something onto the frame. If you are just going into a function,
认为它更多地推入了一种设置格式，一个帧，进入堆栈。所以你有这些堆栈帧。所以当你崩溃并得到一个堆栈转储时，你实际上可以查看它并寻找堆栈。所以你有这些堆栈帧。所以当你崩溃并得到一个堆栈转储时，你实际上可以查看它并寻找帧。但事实证明，并非每个函数都需要将某些东西推入帧。如果你只是进入一个函数，
writing some value in memory, and then going to another function, for instance, that middle function doesn't need anything pushed into the stack. And so GCC will actually just make it so that it calls through that function. Yeah, that's right. So this can happen. And depending on, like I said, the level of optimization,
在内存中写入一些值，然后进入另一个函数，例如，那个中间函数不需要任何东西被推入堆栈。所以GCC实际上会使它通过那个函数调用。是的，没错。所以这可能会发生。而且取决于，就像我说的，优化的水平，
it becomes worse and worse. And so GCC is incredibly, well, GDB is incredibly good at using GCC and examining the code and the memory and being able to unwind. But automated tools can have difficulty doing that. And so there are several cases where I end up looking at a memory dump of the stack and looking for addresses that were in the code space that were essentially function pointers or like, you know, return addresses by hand to unwind the stack. Oh, God. To try to find problems.
它变得越来越糟。所以GCC非常，嗯，GDB非常擅长使用GCC并检查代码和内存，并能够展开。但自动化工具在这样做时可能会有困难。所以有几个案例，我最终查看堆栈的内存转储，并寻找代码空间中的地址，这些地址本质上是函数指针，或者像，你知道，返回地址，手动展开堆栈。哦，天哪。试图寻找问题。
So do you do the GCC-E where it gives you the function pointers for all the functions? Oh, well, there's lots of techniques. But no, I mean, typically you can have the binary and you can do like the object dump, is it? Or the disassembly, basically. So I do a lot with assembly. So I can just disassemble the code, look at the disassembly basically so i do a lot with assembly so i can just disassemble the code look at the disassembly look at the address and you know kind of tell what it was doing um but like very very by hand and i said there's probably some way to script it but it ended up being just faster to do it by hand and like scan through the stack where
那么你会使用GCC-E吗？它会为你提供所有函数的函数指针？哦，有很多技巧。但不是，我的意思是，通常你可以拥有二进制文件，然后你可以做类似对象转储（object dump）的操作，是吗？或者基本上就是反汇编。所以我经常使用汇编。所以我可以直接反汇编代码，查看反汇编结果，查看地址，然后你知道，基本上就能判断出它在做什么。嗯，但这完全是手工完成的，我说过可能有一些脚本化的方法，但最终手工完成并扫描堆栈会更快，
we were and like look for things which i knew to be in code space and then almost universally those ended up being the return addresses cool yeah i have a friend whose dad uh uh was in russia working in the commerce space and he was designing ATM machines and for some reason the ATM machine You know the display like hadn't even arrived yet But they were under like incredible time pressure and they were trying to do all the logic and things like that And all they had was the you know, you know that beeping the ATM makes when you put your password in and things like that So he could alter the tone of that, but that was it.
我们当时所在的位置，寻找那些我知道在代码空间中的东西，几乎所有这些最终都是返回地址。酷，是的，我有一个朋友，他的父亲在俄罗斯从事商业空间工作，他当时在设计ATM机。由于某种原因，ATM机的显示屏甚至还没到货，但他们承受着巨大的时间压力，他们试图完成所有的逻辑等等。他们所拥有的只是，你知道，当你输入密码时ATM发出的那种哔哔声之类的东西。所以他只能改变那个声音的音调，仅此而已。
Like, that was the only sort of interface between this computer and the real world. And so in desperation, he actually had it play different notes based on, you know, different issues. Like, he was basically putting in print statements but in audio form and so it would say you know and you'd have to like think about what those frequencies like what those pitches were and then say okay you know i mean he probably couldn't get it down to like the single number i couldn't distinguish a seven from an eight but he'd like look at that and say okay all right we got into this part of the function and then he'd like go back i was just like oh my god so i've never done it but i've almost done it and had someone told me that they have done it before where print statement ultimately the print handler right like
就像，那是这台计算机与现实世界之间唯一的接口。所以出于绝望，他实际上让它根据不同的问题发出不同的音调。就像，他基本上是在以音频形式放入打印语句，所以它会发出声音，你必须思考这些频率，这些音高是什么，然后说，好吧，你知道，我的意思是，他可能无法将其精确到单个数字，我无法区分7和8，但他会看着它说，好吧，我们进入了函数的这一部分，然后他会回去。我当时就想，天哪，所以我从来没做过，但我几乎做过，有人告诉我他们以前做过，打印语句最终会调用打印处理程序，对吧？
twiddles bits on a ur or sends it an assist call or whatever right so you can put your own code there and um a person told me that they had done debugging with an led blinking so actually the print statement you could send you know via on and off led pulses and then have another computer basically like detect the light and look for on off on off on off and basically retrieve the binary. So an LED-based UART, basically. That's amazing. Like LED read by a camera. It's like LED Morse code.
在UART上拨动位，或者发送系统调用等等，对吧？所以你可以在那里放入你自己的代码。嗯，有人告诉我他们曾用LED闪烁进行调试。实际上，打印语句可以通过LED的开和关脉冲发送，然后让另一台计算机基本上检测光线，寻找开-关-开-关，并基本上检索二进制数据。所以，基本上是一个基于LED的UART。太神奇了。就像用摄像头读取LED。就像LED摩尔斯电码。
Yeah, doing Morse code that was invented like 300 years ago or something, right? You could do it. Oh, man. So, yeah, your friend could have actually just had a modem, right? Like it's like... You could have done stack had a modem right like it's like you could have like done stack dumps and everything not what he was complaining about
是的，做摩尔斯电码是300年前发明的，对吧？你可以做到。天哪。所以，是的，你的朋友其实完全可以用调制解调器，对吧？就像……你可以做堆栈转储等等，这不是他在抱怨的事情。
oh my gosh oh man um so we have a few questions from the from the twitch stream before we wrap it up. So someone asked, why is print debugging the best form of debugging? Andrew asks. So I still use a lot of print debugging. For me, it's the fastest. I don't know if I would call it the best form of debugging because I am definitely not a good debugger like Patrick is. What?
天哪，天哪。嗯，在我们结束之前，我们有几个来自Twitch直播的问题。有人问，为什么打印调试是最好的调试形式？Andrew问。所以我仍然使用大量的打印调试。对我来说，这是最快的。我不知道我是否会称它为最好的调试形式，因为我绝对不像Patrick那样是一个好的调试器。什么？
But I tend to almost always use prints. And it's just because I usually get what I need faster than stepping through with the debugger. So yeah, what's your opinion on it? I mean, it's a balance, right? Like I typically try one thing and then give up and try another way and go back and forth and back and forth. But I too also typically end up opting for print statements when possible.
但我倾向于几乎总是使用打印。这只是因为我通常比使用调试器单步执行更快地得到我需要的东西。所以，是的，你对此有什么看法？我的意思是，这是一种平衡，对吧？就像我通常尝试一种方法，然后放弃，尝试另一种方法，来回反复。但我通常在可能的情况下也会选择打印语句。
Yeah. I mean, it depends on a lot of it depends on sort of like the dynamics of your program. Like if your program has to hit a database and do all these other things and the program itself isn't too complex, maybe like a debugger would it would be better every time but uh but yeah patrick's right there's really no silver bullet it just depends on the circumstance but i think that's part of what being like i feel like it's an old school crime detective right like you have to have your hunch and when you work yeah right when you work
是的。我的意思是，这取决于很多因素，取决于你的程序的动态。如果你的程序必须访问数据库并做所有这些其他事情，而程序本身并不太复杂，也许调试器每次都会更好，但是的，Patrick是对的，真的没有灵丹妙药，这完全取决于具体情况。但我认为这就是成为……我觉得这就像一个老派的犯罪侦探，对吧？你必须有你的直觉，当你工作时，是的，对吧，当你工作时，
in software i don't know i feel like i developed some sort of hunch like you know the bits of the code you don't trust and those are the first ones i go after first yeah and i think part of being good at it is just having a more intuitive feel of where to go first makes you get there that much faster but picking the wrong one can just cost you tons and tons of time right because you're just barking up the wrong tree. Yeah, like if you, this is one thing that I've learned over the years. If you have a bug in some code, it's extremely likely you have more than one bug
在软件领域，我不知道，我觉得我培养出了一种直觉，你知道你不信任的代码片段，那些是我首先要处理的。是的，我认为擅长这一点的一部分就是对首先去哪里有更直观的感觉，这让你更快地到达那里。但选择错误的方向可能会浪费你大量的时间，因为你找错了方向。是的，就像如果你，这是我多年来学到的一件事。如果你的代码中有错误，极有可能你有不止一个错误
in the same code. Because what happens is that bug starts setting up sort of a false assumptions for the rest of your code in that same block. And it's like, it seems like, I don't know if it's just like a self-fulfilling prophecy or whatever But I mean we had it a month ago where we had a bug and then sure enough a week later We had another bug in the same function and it just always seems to be that way So whenever I see a bug I become like just really Like I just start scouring that part of the code base because uh there's
在同一段代码中。因为发生的情况是，那个错误开始为同一块代码中的其余部分设定某种错误的假设。这看起来，我不知道这是否只是像自我实现的预言之类的。但我的意思是，一个月前我们遇到了一个错误，然后果然一周后我们在同一个函数中又遇到了另一个错误，情况似乎总是这样。所以每当我看到一个错误，我就变得非常……我就开始彻底搜查那部分代码库，因为嗯，
almost always more work to do um someone asks should we use lldb instead of gdb um it says to be more advanced than gdb so i can answer this one um if you're on mac you have to use lldb you can actually build gdb um but you probably don't want to. The short answer is LLDB is for LLVM. So if you're using Clang, Clang++, or any of the LLVM, Objective-C, any of the LLVM-based compilers, then you want to be using LLDB. Now, I think, you know, you can use LLDB for GCC compiled code, I believe. And I think you can go, you can actually, both of them work both ways.
几乎总是有更多的工作要做。嗯，有人问我们应该使用lldb而不是gdb吗？它说比gdb更先进，所以我可以回答这个问题。如果你在Mac上，你必须使用lldb，你实际上可以构建gdb，但你可能不想这样做。简短的回答是LLDB是为LLVM准备的。所以如果你使用Clang、Clang++或任何LLVM、Objective-C，任何基于LLVM的编译器，那么你想要使用LLDB。现在，我认为，你知道，我相信你可以将LLDB用于GCC编译的代码。而且我认为你可以，实际上，两者都可以双向工作。
But there's no reason to do that. Like LLDB is going to be the best for LLVM code and GDB for GCC code. So that's a, and Jiggygy asked that so thanks for your question jiggy i i never used lltb but i don't use that much either so yeah i probably osx is the reason why most people i think end up on clang recently yeah yeah clang is uh is is pretty awesome. It is really annoying because we have some bits of our code that I work in that are compiled, like the same code compiled both with GCC and Clang for different reasons.
但没有理由这样做。LLDB对于LLVM代码是最好的，GDB对于GCC代码是最好的。所以这是一个，Jiggygy问了这个问题，所以谢谢你的提问，Jiggy。我从未使用过LLDB，但我也不怎么使用它，所以是的，我可能……OSX是大多数人最近最终使用Clang的原因。是的，是的，Clang非常棒。这真的很烦人，因为我们工作中的一些代码片段是编译的，比如同一段代码因为不同的原因同时用GCC和Clang编译。
And the set of flags is not compatible between them. So there are... Oh, right. So many are, but not all. And so we occasionally end up modifying the GCC portion for some reason and then finding out we up modifying like the gcc portion for some reason and then finding out like we have problems in the clang portion yeah i was a late adopter to clang for one reason and it was that clang didn't have support for address sanitizer like it had it but
而且标志集在它们之间是不兼容的。所以有……哦，对了。很多是兼容的，但不是全部。所以我们偶尔会因为某种原因修改GCC部分，然后发现我们修改了GCC部分，然后发现我们在Clang部分遇到了问题。是的，我曾是Clang的晚期采用者，原因是一个，Clang不支持地址清理器（address sanitizer），虽然它有，但
it wasn't built in and it was super goofy um but they have that recently so i actually just uh homebrew installed clang and i'm using that for almost everything and it's amazing big fan so someone was also criticizing my uh use of multimeter but i did look it up on google and the little pronunciation key assuming i read it right actually said both are valid multimeter or multimeter. Really? Like how does a pronunciation key do both? So if you just type define multimeter into Google, it gives you the pronunciation. I'm doing it right now for the stream. Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
它不是内置的，而且非常笨拙。但他们最近有了这个功能，所以我实际上刚刚用Homebrew安装了Clang，我几乎用它做所有事情，这太棒了，我是大粉丝。所以有人也在批评我使用万用表（multimeter），但我确实在谷歌上查了一下，那个小的发音键，假设我读对了，实际上说两者都是有效的，multimeter 或 multimeter。真的吗？发音键怎么会两种都对？所以如果你在谷歌上输入 define multimeter，它会给你发音。我正在为直播做这件事。是的，做吧，做吧，做吧。
This is so fascinating for all of the listeners. It has like the comma and the other one. You're right. Yeah, it has both, multimeter and multimeter. And I only know that the one on the right is multimeter because the one on the left has the E with the line over it, which I know has a long E. I remember my high school English classes, but I'm surprised you can't click on it and get a speech vocal. Oh yeah. This is fascinating podcasting.
这对所有听众来说都太迷人了。它有逗号和另一个。你是对的。是的，它两者都有，multimeter 和 multimeter。我只知道右边那个是 multimeter，因为左边那个有带横线的E，我知道那是长元音E。我记得我的高中英语课，但我很惊讶你不能点击它并获得语音发音。哦，是的。这是迷人的播客。
Well, I think that's a wrap for me for today. Yeah. Um, so thanks everybody. Oh, uh, so we should uh so we should we should definitely say that uh we're close to 10 000 subscribers which is amazing um thank you guys almost there tell your mom tell your friends yeah like so we've never pleaded for subscribers before i think we are pleading for subscribers i think we've pleaded before no we haven't i have more pride than i'm just kidding no we have no pride we're pleading for subscribers uh get us a 10 000 we're at 97 something so uh we're very or just download it multiple times uh yeah actually how does feed burner just define a subscriber it's arbitrary statistic it's interesting because what i'm going to assume is most people download it and email it to 10 of their friends or like put it up on dropbox or
好吧，我想我今天就到这里了。是的。嗯，所以谢谢大家。哦，所以我们应该……所以我们应该绝对说，我们快要达到10,000名订阅者了，这太棒了。谢谢你们，快到了，告诉你的妈妈，告诉你的朋友。是的，我们以前从未乞求过订阅者，我想我们是在乞求订阅者，我想我们以前乞求过。不，我们没有。我有更多的自尊，我只是开玩笑。不，我们没有自尊，我们在乞求订阅者。让我们达到10,000，我们现在有9700多，所以我们非常……或者只是多次下载它。是的，实际上FeedBurner是如何定义订阅者的？这是一个任意的统计数据。这很有趣，因为我假设大多数人下载它并将其通过电子邮件发送给他们的10个朋友，或者把它放在Dropbox上，或者
something i don't know what all the cool kids do these days and yeah like everyone do an email chain or a pyramid scheme or something whatever they're putting on floppy disks and like leaving it on their friends desks and then like their friends are listening to it too so we actually have like 10x the distribution and i'm not going to pretend that some person has it like downloading on every one of their devices and so it's like copied on 10 devices so uh uh we yeah so we need uh exactly 225 more subscribers to hit 10k which would be totally awesome so if you're listening to this and you haven't downloaded the podcast go download it right now yeah i mean i'm pretty sure it does a good job de-duping so i don't think you'll be another subscriber but do it anyways you never
什么的，我不知道现在的酷孩子们都在做什么。是的，就像每个人都做一个电子邮件链或传销之类的，无论他们把什么放在软盘上，然后把它留在朋友的桌子上，然后他们的朋友也在听。所以我们实际上有10倍的分发量，我不会假装有人在他们的每一台设备上下载它，所以它被复制到了10台设备上。所以我们……是的，我们需要正好225个以上的订阅者才能达到1万，那将是非常棒的。所以如果你正在听这个，并且还没有下载这个播客，现在就去下载吧。是的，我的意思是，我很确定它在去重方面做得很好，所以我不认为你会成为另一个订阅者，但无论如何都要做，你永远
know oh dear oh man okay now we're kidding but seriously uh thank you guys for subscribing um you guys for subscribing. You guys have been signing up for Audible through our link. We really appreciate that. And Amazon. Do our Amazon stuff. And the Amazon, the book of the show. That helps pay our ridiculous network costs to serve it to everyone. But thank you guys, and we will catch you guys in a month or so.
不知道。哦，亲爱的，天哪，好吧，现在我们在开玩笑，但说真的，谢谢你们订阅。你们一直在通过我们的链接注册Audible。我们真的很感激。还有亚马逊。做我们的亚马逊相关的事情。还有亚马逊，节目的书。这有助于支付我们向每个人提供服务的荒谬网络成本。但谢谢你们，我们大约一个月后再见。
The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向我和Patrick提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。